hey make sure you mic is on it's a
livestream so you know what that means
I'm gonna ask the question can you hear
us can you hear me now can you hear us
confirm we can hear you yes hello Peter
all read harder on top of it buddy tasty
- we'll get to your question right away
what it do Robert Becerra Mimi M if you
guys are not able to read today's theme
is tell us your favorite childhood
movies and shows and/or shows we're
getting a lot of suggestions already
over the hedge hook - flushed away Oh
flushed away nobody brings that movie up
we're friends now flushed away isn't
that the Hugh Jackman one yeah they like
one of our Jackman few uh CG movies
Zathura that's a good one too
Teletubbies classic flipper with Elijah
why I appreciate you saying
flipper with Elijah Wood Caleb axel love
you too buddy
my my Elijah Wood childhood movie was
Huck Finn oh that's a good one
when was the faculty what's up reject
nation what's up max sadly you know what
I I should have spent I should have
probably change this question up a
little bit what just I'm just gonna kick
it off with this what childhood movie is
an unusual childhood movie for you like
don't worry
mine was a scream I used to watch it
every Sunday after church I would we go
to this place called pizza guy which is
near Jon's home gonna play a club meets
a guy after church on Sundays and then
immediately after I go home and watch my
v8 my dad would get like rent laser
discs of movies and then we'd VHS tape
record them so we had high quality video
tape recordings of these films and mine
was scream that was my that was my jam
back in the day scream John you got a
got a weird one I well John was very
censored in
in ways yeah I mean in ways you couldn't
watch the citizens you watching mr. mrs.
Humphrey you didn't let him watch a fire
oh goodness now I'm reliving traumas
there was see might my dad would he had
this brilliant system and I don't know
if I should say this out loud but you
know system but porn that's right I grew
up on a lot of porn no no there it I
don't know if it's a criminais ting now
VHS is not the dominant format but my
dad would make little copies of
basically films we would rent and he
made me a copy of Terminator 2 and he
cut out the like to crazy stuff
imagining ya at scene yeah I mean he
basically left it to the point where I
knew it was gonna happen but I didn't
see the Corbett you know you just like
check out the gore gags toned down some
of the icky like mental hospital stuff
and then yeah so I watched the heck out
of Terminator 2 and then when I was a
slightly older but you know child still
the thing I really got down with the
thing well your dad worked on the thing
yeah I know so your dad was like either
way I don't care how traumatizing this
is gonna be for you young Johnny that's
what you're watching my [ __ ] movie
yeah this Lost Boys yeah big business
planes trains Terminator 2 my dad got a
laserdisc if you guys know laser discs
are because come you guys are naming
childhood movies that are like
definitely not my childhood I was
already an adult laser discs before
there were DVDs or these giant ass dis
they were like the size of records but
weighed like 10 pounds I never I've
never gotten to use one or witness one
being used they if they're great are
they no they were mean and yeah I know
nostalgia for it and my dad gave me a he
got himself a copy of Terminator 2 and
he got me one a copy of Toronto isn't
his yeah my dad would know I'm sure you
watch your major to as three year old
you're putting your goddamn laser discs
and you know what Greg let's watch your
copy tonight yeah you mean it died back
into the chat yes
right we gotta say by the Bell
Teletubbies Teletubbies I didn't watch
those up it didn't have cable never a
poor child but we had many laser discs
instead of cable sound off who's excited
to see Saved by the Bell come back I
haven't seen the ad yet but uh I I saw
the trailer for it and that I thought
the trailer for then you say by the belt
looks really good I didn't grow up on
the show but should the new one looks
pretty good
hey man you got how you'll have to catch
up it's you're gonna have to the cabmen
is really thick now oh my god oh we got
our first super chat today oh oh we're
bringing it back I could hop in on this
one
hey did you ever go on set of wizards
did you ever do that
not that we were really close friends
with David Henry when he was in eighth
grade I went to method arete to is our
eighth grade class and I was on like set
for every episode for the first epic see
correctly correct every episode of the
first season of Wizards of Waverly Place
gotta meet Selena Gomez before she was
[ __ ] Selena Gomez and she was super
nice I don't know if she's changed but
imagine she's still a nice human being
you know and Phineas and Ferb I knew the
head writer for a little bit really
gentlemen really really funny guy really
funny guy forgot ja he's related to
someone honey
Josh from Drake and Josh I would see him
all the time at LA Fitness most drug
addiction days yeah uh oh good that
Drake which one which one was a heavy
rake which was a heavier one that became
a really serious actor for a while yeah
I know
I think it's Josh Peck and Drake Bell
right yeah heck yeah
Drake Bell starred in superhero movie
which isn't great but is
funny yeah that's true that's true yeah
but yeah yeah
John chime in on Carter's comment oh
goodness I'm sorry never mind we're
moving on yeah what else do we got in
this chat Power Rangers the movie that's
a movie
certainly a child Bryan saying that or
Byron Power Rangers the movie absolutely
a hundred percent use you lose Oh
or my favorite line it smells like
teenager I thought it was a Robert
Englund my entire life and in like five
years ago fool me with that yeah that's
a movie I want to go back and watch
again to see because I have it legit
like the last time I watch that was like
over 15 years ago probably right right
as like as if I was probably a kid at my
grandparents house okay
oh okay so we have Godzilla's king of
the monsters 1956 Oh small soldiers I
did like that movie a lot back when
Beetlejuice that was definitely a
childhood favorite childhood movie of
mine scared the crap out of me and I
couldn't stop watching it I didn't get
the movie until I was like a tween so I
just thought it was a cartoon for the
longest time oh my god sorry
yeah I would watch the cartoon a lot and
that was my Beetlejuice until years
later on this was a movie we got someone
in the chat saying maverick is saying
the patriot with Mel Gibson oh my I
definitely watch the patron in the
theaters when I was a kid but my
childhood movie of Mel Gibson was
actually rants ransom oh yeah give me
back my son yeah so any kid if you ever
kid ever gets kidnapped make sure to say
those exact words by the way I'll be
back my family back my son and they'll
do it I've seen it happen guys oh [ __ ]
talky mushroom hahahaha
bye kid microphone at
[Music]
you know it's singular the most
embarrassing scene most cringy scene in
that movie is when um when when he's
when he chops his kid off at school and
Tony oh man Daris in the movie and he
imagines like standing up to the bully
dad yeah and all the kids are phrases
like I love spike so embarrassing oh
we're gonna have to Spy Kids 3 thank you
and Issa that's a really sweet of you
you're so sweet birthday and thank you
joy you happy early birthday keep it
looking on Thursday do another live
stream Ryan H is saying home alone too I
wouldn't I would meet you there I grew
up way more home alone too that at home
alone one constantly were to watch that
Trump scene he's good with comedy just
like how we did with saying about
drinking that bleach and [ __ ] yeah very
committed to the [ __ ] doing set her is
by saying what you shouldn't say a lot
of love for Spy Kids in here it's up to
path max Rutley but we got here saw jaws
and a Hellraiser I want to know what
your childhood was like oh my greatness
Gabriel's I say ice ages I saw you took
me to see that yeah GJ Johnny I was
about to bring that up John's dad as
part of the Directors Guild of America
so every once in a while would we go to
these early if you still go to those
yeah yeah not as much during especially
during the quarter no I I mean if there
was some kind of remote DGA screening
series I'm sure he would jump in on that
but but yeah he doesn't go as much as he
used to because I'm Maria Hammond I've
seen the Mafia
Brendan V Sharkboy and Lavagirl for the
win hey Brenda fees just for you dude I
got hella bandanas over here I'm gonna
put one on every 20 minutes
Spy Kids 3 game over from Robert you
know Bobbie Edna
as Madison hopefully under coming on the
channel Bobby Enders her brother he was
in that movie movie oh it's a small
world after all
random Andy's channel thank you for the
super chat buddy you get the mic to use
them all my man the pagemaster was my
[ __ ] growing up you know yeah they dress
I've never seen Richie Rich
I've not either okay never seen Richie
Rich yeah I used to love small soldiers
but especially like the pagemaster was
one I would watch every day there were a
couple movies I would watch every day
for just long stretches of time growing
up and the pagemaster was definitely one
you know Macaulay Culkin has had two
Macaulay Culkin that's my home alone I
got much later in life I remember small
soldiers being a lot darker more intense
and I expected when they used to make
kids movies like that as pg-13 wasn't it
I think I believed that one was Peter
soft surprisingly pg-13 putting in
nuclear codes and [ __ ] inside of the
toys you stole my use them as weapons
gorgonites organized all going at scum
must yeah man no certain gentleman is
not strike lady Thank You random Andy's
China I love your profile pic you really
oh I do batteries not included
I remember the lead character in that
movie gets like stabbed in the hand by
one of the toys Oh Oh so ginger I've
never you know there's a lot of love for
Matilda Matilda yeah I used to love that
but this is this is the video where I
reveal all the [ __ ] about me that people
are not gonna like never seen Matilda oh
it's never seen Richie Rich I can't
vouch for Richie Rich I know it came
from a comic strip but Matilda I think
still holds up and Danny to be
directed that it's like one of his oh
you know project detracted double
feature those your favorite childhood
and adult ducktales was just watching a
video about ducktales that mentioned
Saturday morning cartoons you'll see
that video tomorrow up on YouTube Plus
react was something very specific
Britney Britney ylang-ylang killing the
game is this a view many years ago or is
this of a child that is yours John I
want you Christopher Walken impression
to this setting okay okay you betcha
it's gonna sound like a robot shorting
out it's not my best I turn my mic off
but the best my walking oh I'll have to
read you I'm sorry my bad you're walking
now totally did not light but on the
live stream it doesn't pop up and and so
my bad see we're reading the chat told
you yes yes not making eye contact and
now we'll read it so you can actually
tell we're saying oh your man
the movies you constantly list every
week first operand you thank you so much
is that your daughter in the thumbnail
I'm assuming so unless she shrunk she's
suffering from a terrible this is a cool
looking kiddo a big picture um okay so
private that you always list movies that
or just made me think you're gonna like
totally get along my girlfriend Friday
13th out of all the horror franchises
that's her favorite she's always trying
to get me to walk like we watch all them
with her food but Super Mario Brothers
the movie yeah see I I have fragmented
memory I haven't seen that since I was a
very young child and I have like weird
fragmented memories at best of it yes
and now I've just seen every like pop
culture think piece lately and I've been
hunkering to watch that movie again it's
a man sometimes that what's laserdisc I
explain what laserdisc is but I know we
often fall behind this chat okay what do
we got here Ivan that's such a sweet
thing thank you by the way what's up hey
favorite childhood food pizza guy yeah
who this Maria's haven't seen the The
Sound of Music I did watch that more
than a few times growing up
Erica Tuesday can't name one borrower so
good I was just about to shoot you a
text because I realized I didn't realize
saying Return of the Jedi is number one
and only laserdisc he's ever seen only I
love this okay you talk about laserdisc
I the only one I've ever seen I remember
it well I found it in the woods one day
after killing a deer I didn't V London
John round two you're gonna do who's the
person you like to imperson you did
recently that randomly impressed me Oh
shhh John Benjamin yeah John Benjamin
the voice of our mother into the
megaphone my mic so my mics on the
problem is this is what musicians must
go through because now I can't hear
myself well enough
too late this in president sound like
anybody talking into a microphone the
fact that we're putting the megaphone
into the mic you can't even hear John's
impression echoing to get like a few
mics going on you know have a surround
sound system Sharkboy and Lavagirl I
don't know about that I don't know about
that clips for the church that movie is
I am fascinated by because it I just
when I see it anytime I see a clip from
it I was I had no Robert Rodriguez likes
shoot for the stars and all that stuff
and I was like this this is not the
technology needed to make this movie
will come to life whose sharp boring
that lava Taylor Lautner that's right
and who was lava girl isn't she some
nobody now nobody now Thank You Brendan
V Jurassic Park
yes Park yeah three years old when I
came out that was the first movie I went
to the theaters I think there's the
first movie I ever saw in the theaters
and scream my head off my parents had to
like take me outside for a little bit
because I was I was too obnoxious they
had beat me in the lobby then fed me
popcorn and so we're going to later show
a very quiet we're in there like PBS was
legit until I got cable I feel that I'm
sorry but there's still good stuff on
PBS go go look rocket power Playhouse
Disney
oh I remember Playhouse Disney yes
Revenge of the Sith is still my favorite
film to this day Wow my favorite of all
filter you Jam but favorite of Star Wars
ooh
Anissa Anissa John you have to do this
one in the best Adam Sandler voice ha no
take-backs
ah the wedding planner has it good with
JLo this is either the most energetic
live streaming a viewer has been at in a
while or the most annoying it's always
special when the megaphone comes really
these guys are great or they're loud
rocket power we are riders oh no Boosh
thank you in this the wedding planner
I I think would have to be you know 50
first dates is pretty great but I would
say like the one that truly feels the
most romantic of Adam Sandler's rom-coms
would be the wedding planner wait a
minute though is there a movie the
wedding singer which wedding planner is
is JLo and Matthew McConaughey
oh all right John Deere bass Matthew
McConaughey fresh they say in the first
sentence the wedding planner was also
big childhood movie I used to watch all
the time my mom we used to watch a bunch
romantic comedy movies together
including ghosts of Girlfriends you know
John could take you out on dating this
and do that exactly and all the while
we're driving there's gonna be in
Lincoln conversion
thank you so much okay Oh Gabriel hates
Teletubbies there is it possible to have
just a genuine feeling toward the
Teletubbies I feel like they're just so
much of a culture meme Oh someone Jambu
springing up Disney XD no is this deep
for the hip teenagers because there's a
completely different market for little
kids and teenagers II got an ASCII
smiley face and a title and their
skateboards and stuff do you guys not
remember that my god do you not Disney
Junior now what oh here we go
hello to Texas here we go this is these
are some of the answers I was looking
for Eric Horstmann
the man with the real rejects tattoo a
real one
excuse me no I like how you look like a
member of the misfits and your picture
here Texas Chainsaw Massacre
it was great we should sample that and
use it I'm gonna add on to the list
[ __ ] never see neverending
story I you know neverending story and
labyrinth I need two bo3 watch because I
know I saw them both as a kid I have
foggy memories of each and I'm to
understand now that one of them is is
very good still and one of them is is
not and I I've been told that labyrinth
is the one that's still good but I don't
know if people should sound off in the
comments cuz that was like a pretty
freaky ass movie - Texas Chainsaw
Massacre isn't that your favorite horror
movie
depending on the it wines ending on
which Tuesday I don't know I don't know
if I would go out my favorite favorite
favorite but it's in that you know top
ten range of like I would say it on a
certain day probably I forgot why we
watched it when we were living together
and I had the biggest headache when it
was done is a shrill just my head it is
a shrill a smooth I don't think I'll
ever watch it again it was it so bad to
an alley when they're all laughing at
the table all those oh my God my head
hurts
God if you want to have a fun time
testing your horror marriage by the way
thank you Eric Spanx to you I wanna I
mean you know we can yeah we you know
it'll be all three of us shouts out
though to cavity colors these been
putting up on Instagram this guy makes
great horror art in like t-shirts and
stuff and he's been putting up these
guests collages of like here are six
eyeballs or six mouths or something from
various movies and like seeing who could
guess and one of them had that eyeball
close-up and I was like I don't know all
of these but know that what do you think
your little sincere fun facts are what's
gonna make this live stream entertaining
John you know they're they're not do you
think good that's
we're gonna help us out they're not good
for search engine optimization or watch
time now sorry we should move on venom
to terminator dark fate yes
what's marketable now George Lopez
George Lopez Oh George George Lopez show
was a funny one
Ivan Carey L had a crush on David Henry
now a lot of men did you should
introduce and half the woman in the
world did dude Zachary Back to the
Future movies amen to that yes I want to
shout out of is enza's netiq
double-oh-seven because you've been
holding it down for cheese just this
whole stream mmm and I just got great
commitment to the meme I guess siege of
Mandalore oh goodness
I don't argue to the siege of matter no
what the hell seizure Mandalore is I
think people were asking for Clone Wars
draft some people were a tree has been
delayed we're catching up to this chat
and people are really defending Drake
Bell in here I'm sorry I'm sorry Alex
summers thank you so much dudu thank you
so much oh this is a fun way to mix up
the chat we thought your little your
little shirt story or was telling me I
wasn't listening something about your
things are you like I don't know yeah
okay so I loved it as a child too so
perfect Alex summers all right look okay
all right who can I sign you I don't
know just do where the hell you want
yeah favorite cereals of all time mine
was smart berry crunch cinnamon toast
crunch quick O's and packs man cereal
you guys are awesome thank you Alex
summers which I believe is a Alex winter
isn't that Piru
hmm well the summers and Alex summers at
but I think thought I rose his brother
and some of the comics either way out
summers thank you so much love your
profile pic and this is an easy answer
fruity pebbles
I love fruity pebbles when I first I was
like must been 1918 when I first
discovered a thing called marijuana John
their favorite cereal man and we'll get
back to the quitter topic at hand which
is favorites share childhood movies and
shows thank you Alex summers is really
kind of you thank you honestly when I
was growing up I got I think i had berry
berry kicks the most so kicks was
definitely one I remember once I
convinced my mom to buy me a box of
Reese's puffs cereal and that was like
Christmas because it really does taste
like Reese's I better tell him I'm just
alginate for a lot of cereal though and
it's funny cuz I don't hardly ever eat
cereal anymore and I feel like I owe it
to myself to at least catch up with the
classic monster cereals that's fair what
does packs man though I don't think I
know that is it related to pac-man I
don't know never heard of that cereal
you know what else I John say some of
your other favorite cereals mmm well
let's see the cinnamon toast crunch I
think we had Froot Loops I didn't have
very many pebble based cereals but I did
have Froot Loops we didn't get a lot of
Marsh mellow ones in my home growing up
Erica Tuesday wait what's going on over
there
ooh spider-man 2 is a great childhood
movie right there - absolutely
The Matrix absolutely I don't know why
thank you Lisa Marie for mentioning the
matrix I don't know why I never thought
about that
I came out right when I was like 9 or 10
years old of course the matrix was my
movie Joe what the [ __ ] are you looking
so tired of talking Johnson you're
looking when I was
about cereal I'm actually moving I am
reading what two people in the chat are
talking about so I can see because
because apparently Carter Lovejoy
I thought you had an old dance dance
revelution arcade cabinet I was like
what like cuz used to go nuts over DDR
back in the day and they and Ericka and
Carter talked about DDR and I am
terrible at that game
thank you John you're welcome that was
great John there's no room for fun
during those room we gotta go right this
engagement does it look like other live
streamers have fun if we get to 200
concurrently I have a surprise so keep
it keep it up people all right guys well
we fell behind all right what do we got
here or Sharkboy and Lavagirl
oh okay Carter Lovejoy got him again
right on target
Carter is saying thank you by the way
Carter for the super chat but it means a
lot okay that's my gimmick right now I
can never use that again yes this is how
you transmit what scallion barn oh yeah
is it okay I never had it but I think I
think Caillou is like a show those are
you and me is it is it the French
cartoon it's not mozzie but it's like
one of those types of things
mm-hmm I assumed I would actually be
curious to see an episode or to the
matrix Lisa Marie to varsity blues oh my
goodness no joke I saw that with my
family when I was a little kid I don't
think they knew when we were gonna go
watch Hilary B is saying varsity blues
and Thelma and when the teacher starts
stripping and then when the girl comes
out with the whipped cream oh that's
right allele ordered you should not get
sexually aroused when your parents are
right next to you oh yeah those are no
movies to watch and if you do therapies
not frowned upon as much as it used to
be anymore guys no shame in the game
let's see or therapy all my therapy
sessions are about watching varsity
blues Brokeback Mountain species right
over my past I paid my therapist for
there's no point in shielding you to the
realities of life every time I walk in a
therapy what's the next movie today
what's the next one that traumatized you
Hey that's our next live event traumatic
film clips Oh Erik horseman Jon do your
best
Jensen Ackles impression that's Dean
from Supernatural saying Erik Horseman's
next super chat question here go go John
okay sorry I'm favorite kid shows
Thundercats ho I don't know how the ho
ho how old are you Eric house
thundercats thundercats how to be the
80s right oh my god yes why it's a
childhood favorite of his Eric it's it's
it's David Gandy who gets progressively
older but yet Eric is in the 70s Eric
has seen a lot America handle it
Eric's the best man there's amazing
Eric's one of my favorite people
thundercats ever seen Thundercats gotta
add that to a list lion-o man I do want
to say really fast this is off topic I
recently started the show Hannibal the
one with Mads Mikkelsen as Hannibal and
I gotta say guys that show is [ __ ]
incredible hmm it is so addicting I'm on
season 2 now so damn its I for the
longest time I was under the impression
it's NBC how good can a Hannibal show on
NBC be
it is shockingly true and shockingly
gross there's so many times I'm watching
it with my girlfriend I'm going oh my
god stop there was something having a
recent episode I almost didn't watch it
because it was that gruesome I really
want to see it we got plenty of time on
your hands John I always keep holding
off because I'm like we do reactions
we're not going to or watching our home
time who and Nyssa live oh she's got
another one John do you miss okay who
Jon Favreau director there was also a
childhood movie for me and this says
thank you by the way innocent as a
thriller was also a great childhood
movie for me never seen super it's the
second humanity movie I haven't seen
anyone show super Jenny you were never a
child you were just born into your
mid-teens
I watched Judge Dredd lock screen watch
any of these like actual children's
movies I mean that's you have see this
is the thing is is is maybe this is
weird in this room but like for
everybody I've met who is like a huge
horror junkie I always felt like the odd
person out because they're like oh yeah
you know I grew up on like every
gruesome movie ever like a way to
showcase there's the people who have
been super tired we could do that screen
thing right yes we can but what are
people at are other people listening in
the chat right now bill just varsity
blues The Parent Trap The Parent Trap
never seen The Parent Trap this is what
good lectures are all about both
versions of the parents really I have
the original one is better but you know
I had a crush on Lindsay Lohan at the
time so it's all good Dennis Quaid's in
it oh yeah my dad worked on Breaking
Away so there you go hey listen Oh
spider-man 2002 my brother Jack away he
pulled me out Michael's saying this he
pulled me out of school twice no three
times in my life my brothers pulled me
out of school to go to the theaters to
watch a movie lucky
yeah yeah John wasn't allowed to watch
The Simpsons as a kid so not allowed to
leave school to go to the movies he
pulled me out of school to go watch the
first spider-man movie with Tobey
Maguire that was uh that's a you could
say it was an amazing spell see on let's
see what else did we got here I Dream of
Jeannie oh it's a good show call back to
last week
Oh 2003 from Cedric really that one okay
there's some grease love in here
John do the thingy so we can see some
people on the chat you'll see what we
see guys we organized we're gonna screen
show yeah so we can showcase what's
going on over here share the screen
screen share the screen but then we know
yeah
Oh God oh there we got oh we do that
refit the scooter can we zoom in on this
yes we probably can it's too late the
thing is yeah it is going to affect
every others oh my god John it will lag
a little bit in doing that all right so
what do we got here um all right all
right all right all right all right
Mimi am I've seen this one of yours
Thank You Mimi M for the super chat my
dad got me drunken master mom I think we
shouldn't say as my dad got me drunk
that would call it a master yes drunken
Matt which drunken master are you
talking about though Mimi because some
people just think there's one drunken
master but there was the original one
that made Jackie Chan famous in Hong
Kong and then that was the skyrocket his
career and then many like decades later
he did the legend a drunken master just
drunken master - as they say in Hong
Kong
you see I would call a film enthusiasts
it hasn't seen most of the movies that
are being listed Jeff but I've seen
drunken master yes great this is
everybody has to feel like this at some
point yes so I feeling believe
most you've seen drunken master right
damn right yeah and then we saw which
one did they do on corridor crew though
did they do one or two because I
remember we did the legend a drunken
master is drunken master - yeah yes I
remember you telling me Oh John I pay
attention to things don't worry okay and
then well let's catch up here Carter
Lovejoy's next one over here thanks
Carter playing Dance Dance Revolution
like four hours a day
got an thank you car for that I got
another phone fact I was [ __ ]
incredible
at Dance Dance Revolution you don't say
I was I was the people would bat I
wasn't as good as like the people who
were like spinning in the arcade bunch
of freaks
who'd like but I still battle people
like you'd have that one guy I've had
doing all eight buttons when we were
young genre I wrote the first 30 pages
came up with the plot and John wrote the
like rest the next hundred pages of
Dance Dance Revolution screenplay yes
yes it was like a spin on 80s movies and
it was who's kind of funny again there's
one gag I wrote that I still like and
will use somewhere but I I appreciate
that movie because if you go on Netflix
and you watch the F P and we basically
were trying to make the F P which is a
dance dance revelution 80s like badass
like my brother died playing there's
someone you guys were talking about so
many good movies in this chat right the
Cable Guy I have not seen the Cable Guy
ooh Jackie Chan and someone saying
Jackie Chan the animated show Jam
booster in the chat the Jackie Chan that
that show was called Jackie Chan
adventures yeah where he thought Jackie
I might be in it but if he wasn't uncle
he shows up in the credits g'd i could
do that impression I can't do the actual
Jackie Chan and press the other thing is
if Jackie Chan adventures was on now
then he could just you know like I phone
it in from wherever but you know back
then he actually show up and used to
busy so that's true yeah that's true I
would say oh another childhood movie of
I'm just starting out there feel free to
list random ones never you want John of
what was real Opik okay so I was reading
another company I was engaging with the
fans rumble in the Bronx oh I have a
poster for that it was very much into
that movie as a kid Jackie I was
actually my hero and the bigger and a
big catalyst for why I got really into
film and martial arts or just male know
martial arts that was Walker coming back
Jared Padalecki padalecki is Walker oh
come on
why DSC that's true I'm not he's gotta
be able to do martial arts can Jared
Padalecki do martial arts I don't know
guys how do you feel about Jared
Padalecki reprising the role of Walker
Texas Ranger and which of the upcoming
dance studio heroes do you want
tentacles to play yes really I mean I
loved I love Jared Padalecki I really do
I'm gonna find his Alison oh yeah I
don't know about that I don't know about
Jared Padalecki doing that alright and
then what do I do
yeah screen three okay let's catch up
again here this is a great way for you
to know we're engaging in the superjet
oh it's going to the regular solids yes
two-thirds of our world right here okay
all right what what do we got here Agni
Raj Krishna and hey Niraj Niraj you
haven't been shouted out with a
megaphone yet I don't like that one my
pops worked on night right you know
what's funny about those pics they
totally suit you they do you guys uh
know Niraj I doesn't real one side of
conversation to have her in a live
stream but this totally fits this live
stream portion is only for ya Honey I
Shrunk the Kids
ooh I Reese the first time I saw since
Rick Moranis is the star of Honey I
Shrunk the Kids and he's coming back for
the Disney
movie or show movie yeah well I think
years of retirement and Rick Moranis is
coming back in Honey I Shrunk is a
franchise kids have finally unshrunk and
now he doesn't have to just be a dad
it's gonna be a really dark movie life
was better when I was small you know
what though like as much as I saw Honey
I Shrunk the Kids and I did enjoy it it
made me I remember it making me feel a
weird kind of discomfort growing up and
I I'm not entirely sure like I missed it
the theme park attraction but Honey I
Shrunk the Kids
no Rick Moranis I saw Little Shop of
Horrors for the first time just a couple
days ago I've seen it too yeah it's been
a long time but you liar and I had out
when you're lying you like directly
[Laughter]
assured that's a really fun movie I
recommend after watching it it sent me
down a googol path of what happened Rick
Moranis and so you submitted this Honey
I Shrunk the Kids answer at the right
time thank Niraj did you [ __ ] like I've
always heard the retired you say did you
[ __ ] no did you find out why or like I'd
always just heard that you know he went
to like raise his children or whatever
his wife passed away and thanks for
bringing this up John you found a nice
end to and how he never took a break
from filming oh yeah I heard about that
and the gray is like very personal
cuz it's about a guy grieving over a
punching Wolves no yeah his wife passed
away he decided to step away from film
for a bit and he realized he really
enjoys not being in film so he just
never went back our net worth is 10
million dollars so Rick Moranis from
Ghostbusters Honey I Shrunk the Kids
I Barney from the Flintstones movie yeah
go watch some old episodes of sctv if
you can hunt him down cuz those are some
classic sketch comedy with some great
actors Oh Brendan V what's up homie
Brendan V another he brought a bunch of
bandanas just
for you since we keep saying for you
alright Brendan V is our as one of our
homosexual lovers yes so he was on the
phone with his boyfriend just before we
are gonna do the most stereotypical gay
guy voice for you we'll do it at the
same time John let's go I I can remember
her back tonight my first birthday party
and increase valley girl I can't hear it
right now what does it sound like oh my
Committee to it I mean I guess the
stereotype is just a really like loud
whatever I can remember I can remember
it as you found it I can remember back
to my first birthday party in preschool
I had that no one could break so my dad
had to break it open with his bare hand
what the [ __ ] is this garment that
started all oh my god your dad like
gored and gutted peach and ever since
then I've been looking for a man I just
asked you to fill my relationship with
my father I'm just imagining the upwards
camera angle that's not the way he
evolves well let me read this again I
can remember back to my first birthday
party swap Pikachu pinata Bruce my dad
and break it up with oh my I totally
misread that I thought you were saying
that your dad was mad at you and he
broke a pinata I did not latch on to
what that meant at all
oh my well we had all right so we'll
return back to the comments here what do
we got okay we did that one we got
grease man Erica Tuesday is really
taking up the chat here in the regulars
you're the new moderator for our live
streams 60 Kendall's never been kissed
still never
never been seen by never been John never
been kissed neverending story is a lot
of love for neverending story up in here
okay good
Digimon digital monsters Digimon are the
champions Digimon was a that was you
know what the problem was it got
overshadowed by Pokemon way too much if
you guys seems Digimon damn no I I saw
you did she want I you know what back in
the day I was fervently Pro Pokemon so I
was like this is a ripoff and I didn't
watch it very no man
they were digital monsters that's right
that's right
totally Pocket you can't fit him in a
pocket they going like a little watch
thing they have more personality because
they could actually talk and stuff yeah
what if Pokemon could talk the problem
was they put the word Mon in it and so
American audiences I think associated
Digimon way too closely with Pokemon
well yeah it feels it probably made it
feel like the asylum version like home
home word instead of on words you know
woo Buffy the Vampire Slayer I've only
seen up to the third season I've seen up
to the second to last episode why would
you do that because I wasn't ready to
complete it and then life circumstance
has changed but I haven't had time to
watch well I want those two hours I feel
like I need the right time and I would
need to make some kind of little event
out of it I guess we got a few here from
Archangel why Lion King original Star
Wars Jurassic Park Aladdin a goofy movie
Tarzan Spy Kids Toy Story Treasure
Planet hard to be Caribbean I would say
on this one I would say a Star Wars
trilogy and Lion King absolutely it's
not I know it's not like a weld the
loved Disney animated but I remember
seeing Treasure Planet at like some kind
of Disney screening before it came out
and I really liked at least what they
were going for at least like the the
imagination and the scope of the world
and all that stuff ooh
really beautiful Zion John is taking the
gay guys from me Ivan the st. John is
sexy as [ __ ] don't worry maybe the
ladies will change today
no not happen you never know I just
don't possess the confidence John does
though but it's all become
it's in the world I just sit here be
confident and then you know magic works
out Harry and the Hendersons would you
shaved your head would you still be sexy
I don't think so I don't think I would
so good with the Showtime so what if you
had a short hair what if you like cut
your what if your hair was like actually
short like spiky hair like what if we
okay what if it was like Chris Hemsworth
an extraction sure I mean that was that
used to be my dream haircut were you
getting as much attention as you were
back then uh I don't think so but then
again my ability to recognize those
things was probably even worse back then
so I have no idea
see I don't think I look like there's
the shaved head though I feel like my
head's the wrong shape for it I feel
like I would have a very long shaved
Kristian harloff shape decide not
something looks great looks sexy so yeah
so good all right where we at because
look how comfortable John well I have to
leave Anissa once again thank you Andy
sir the iron Oh John hurry go John take
it away the Iron Giant was my brother
I'm trying vin diesel was my brother's
that I fell in love with it
the sandlot as well as my first crush
was Betty the jet Rodriguez Benny the
jet Benny and the Jets Rodriguez yes
like Elton John well she st. Benny the
jet Rodriguez he didn't read it
correctly you sound like an 80 I took
your long hair I'm tying it because
that's going it's keep flying around
these days I actually have a photo from
not long ago where I was I was taking
and I I had usually I'll fold my hair up
over the top of my head when I condition
it and so like for a moment it's like a
view into the world of short hair John
again so I have a picture of that if
anyone's curious man now
all right well Iron Giant Oh John take
it away I mean your favorite movies love
that movie and I didn't get to see in
the theaters until much later in life I
caught it might my dad rented it I can't
remember if it was my idea or just he
heard it was good but uh yeah like that
was a movie that just grew it's like I
thought it was really fun the first
and then it just grew on me with every
rewatch and now it's like it moves me
and [ __ ]
now it's like I remember I went to catch
one of their matinee screenings at the
new Bev I was like a 2 o'clock show and
I was like late a bit I was like halfway
through the movie late but I was like I
intended to do this day like some some
[ __ ] went wrong and I wasn't able to go
and I remember the guy was like you know
I wasn't halfway through his going and
so I just sat there in the afternoon and
and soaked it in and yeah I was like
even though it was a half film
experience it's still ones like special
to me so yeah much much much love for
the Iron Giant I've never seen the
sandlot I've watched that a lot growing
up - that was a heavy rotator well
that's why this is in love with you
there you go there you go squints can't
swim that that movie really did a number
for barfing scenes now and she stand on
this I also said if you shaved your head
she would still love you well that's you
would still want to jump your bones this
is a good exact quote Benny the jet your
first crush was Benny the jet was he in
the Sandlot is that gene Jeter guys
music - quarantine and chill he's put up
a great setlist - listen listen to it
while I was responding to some messages
gene Jeter go check out channel gremlins
gizmo was the original baby Yoda
I watched gremlins for the first time I
think a year ago dick Miller my goodness
that film holds up like a [ __ ]
still so damn good I am very dude I'm
scared to watch gremlins - because
before I ever watch gremlins 1 I watched
the key & peele
where they're describing gremlins - when
I heard all that really happens in the
movie
do you remember I just remember a coin
it sounds stupid so I what that's all
true no way it's all true that's some
reason I haven't seen gremlins - but I
hear it was pretty incredible still and
its own right it's it's oh it's a work
of art yeah it's definitely it's up
there with the great part twos of all
time makes me good at attention for you
Thank You gene Jeter the punisher 96 are
you going to review the new extreme
action movie I'll tell ya we we were
thinking of doing a stream along for
patreon and perhaps doing a review on
YouTube I want to see if it's like
something bad I don't know I mean from
every review I've heard at least like
the capsules I was like yeah that sounds
like about exactly what I would say it's
gonna be it's like the plots okay Chris
Hemsworth's great the actions awesome
it sounds like like a movie directed by
stunt guys for stunts love you know and
I'm like sounds about like the raid but
with not as compelling that's about as
simple as it sounds
yeah which I mean you know crazy ass
action is not simple sure but yeah but
thank you punished for 96 for that I
don't know do you think you guys think
in there and the chat here do you think
we should review extraction cuz I I do
want to watch it to say the least
that's like about as far as it goes
Princess Bride
grab your LP is saying here in the chat
Princess Bride abso-freakin'-lutely yes
that's a great one very touching films I
was one of the first like romance
thingies I ever saw for sure
mm-hmm and it's great because you get to
be Fred Savage and then you get to be
not Fred Savage so you grow up and you
know like oh no this was a kiss anyway
the bro just in sudden oh yeah it's good
collie saying The Crow that was another
death that was actually an alarm bell
film for my family because I loved it
went like I was like I was like four
years old or whatever when it came out
and before scream I was watching The
Crow all the time and I I think they
were act my dad was actually concerned
that I I wouldn't stop watching the
crowd I was like a little boy well it's
like it's a it's a dark gothic kind of
movies a strange movie and you know like
I'm going to Catholic school watching
this violent ass revenge film are not
very are pretty like reverse from castle
yeah yeah okay that's fair that's fair I
want to shout out Michael where I
appreciate your love for the classic
horror films
Dracula 31 Wolfman 41 good good choices
I've never heard of Dunston checks in
Keene Lagerfeld what is that also Tim
wing the fugitive is a great movie and
if any of you haven't seen the fugitive
because I have seen all movies and have
the authority to guilt you yeah go watch
that movie because that is a great
thriller even still I mean Tim Wing is
also bringing out the movie under siege
under siege which I actually think isn't
alright was there under siege too but on
my train I think or or did they move
speed again there were snakes on a train
no there was there was definitely like a
sequel to one of those Seagal movies and
I think it was understands it on a train
there's a guy I think so that's which
doesn't [ __ ] sense wait yep we're
wonderful first away and it's not gonna
happen
not until we put up the screen John Joe
Justin sudden your shirt because he's
listening the movie that you are wearing
to Edward Scissorhands absolutely
a childhood movie of mine right there
hmm not a childhood movie of mine I saw
it later I maybe saw like glimpses of it
growing up but - yeah nightmare was my
Burton all right what we got here what
do we got we got we got Lake Placid
Danny Phantom mm Oh Brendan be saying
give a bandana to Greg okay I will not
put the bandana around my mouth because
I just don't know how safe 10 is I don't
know the rules entirely of how this all
works if it makes you feel any better
these have not touched my face and I
found them in a bin that's been in a
closet and a home it's been in my
costume been since before Cove at 19 but
I'll leave it up to you know can you can
have one of these I I assure you that
they haven't been nuzzled or cuddled by
me pick up the energy gonna sing you a
song gonna go back to the Chad
Frankenstein Meets The Wolfman still
haven't
where are we at are we caught no are we
caught back up or not this is what
happens you put John and Cheri to find a
fine right here see Thank You Brandon be
by the way is he healthy
I'll Bartlett I just did a shout out for
you and I didn't know what the hell
you're but the beast hood for yeah oh my
god Bartlett yeah we did a Charlie joke
in a previous lesson did we [ __ ] CL
Bartlett ah man I wish I need that but I
made for a funny joke in the shadow
hopefully you caught it cool create a
new reaction series either of you guys
in C is might be too small industry
please create a new reaction series
called movies Greg hasn't seen starting
with Forrest Gump what would be a
trailer we could react to the trailers
for movies that we should have seen that
we haven't seen what would a reaction to
Forrest Gump be like I've never seen
Forrest Gump so I have no idea like what
the experience of reacting before is
come here's what the segment is you
watch the trailer and react to it and
then you watch the movie and you do a
little bit of a review and then that's
the segment there and then you catch up
on classic films so it's like a classic
film review but also it's a reaction and
it's an experiment and it you could tie
it into trailers revisited I'm gonna
keep it sir it was that I think Ella is
a good idea is that the kind of movie
you can do a reaction to I'm not saying
do a reaction the entire movie maybe but
can't but if you did a reaction horse
come can you do it there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff do you think it
would be actually entertaining or would
it be boring it's a long movie but I
feel like it's a it's a very eccentric
movie so I think it would make for a
reaction that has a lot of variety hmm
you know cuz there's war in it there's
you know I don't want to say too many
things but you know it has some
whimsical elements it has some fun stuff
obviously it has some very heartfelt
stuff it has some very hard crushing
stuff you know it goes it runs the gamut
of human emotions and stuff so I think
it would make a reaction there's a lot
of love for Jumanji anger in the chat
right now and I think Jumanji was
absolutely even the Jumanji cartoon this
got brought up last year the Jumanji
cartoon was another one that I really
adored a lot which I kinda wish they did
in the live-action it would have been
cool to kind of explore that I mean the
live at the new the new ones are kind of
doing that and would going into the
Jumanji world invasion for part three
they get sucked in the cartoon or or
they should do what they're doing with
James Dean and they should deep fake or
recreate Robin Williams bring him back
to life kid Jimmy found a plane and do
his robberies impersonation that would
be awesome
oh my my internal organs are screaming
101 Dalmatians yes sir
owner one that makes kind of scary you
know a woman who was kind of like
Cruella De Vil she's she was probably
the first Disney villain probably the
freak me out liar liar Hilary B that's a
great call right there [ __ ] love liar
have you seen it I think you showed it
to me later on
lying in on topic Beverly Hills Cop I've
not seen you haven't seen Beverly Hills
Cop where he puts bananas at the gasping
damn I thought he would have filled it
up by now a big guest
somebody's been asking a lot in various
comments if we have seen the Maze Runner
films which I have not seen a one but I
understand that you've seen at least
I've seen I've seen zoom:1 think it was
better than I then the trailers gave it
gave it off to be what was the actor's
name again the star of that movie Dylan
Dylan Baker
Jake Jake Dylan grazier guys in American
sniper what the [ __ ] is his name
could not think of a man all the mask of
zorro I saw that in theaters that was I
really a like was so dazzled by the
action I wanted
beep Antonio Banderas and also I mean
that was like the sexiest fight scene
ever mask of zero was zero zero zero
actually if he did a zero movie which is
a spin-off of Mega Man that would be
pretty cool or or a Code Geass if he did
zero to ask a big ding Legend of Zorro
Legend of Zorro was a movie I walked out
of well I thought it was terrible
I was watching theaters and then for
some reason I decided just to go back
and finish it I don't know what it was
looks like this is stupid
- but how did I go back one of those
movies which there were too many movies
where I left the theaters it was like
that wasn't as bad maybe I should go
back and watch it go back and I'm like
it's fine transporter - I did that with
Legend of Zorro I did that window
pulling dynamite legend which one is
that there's two horror movies well okay
so it's the one that came after mass
yeah just making sure I'm making sure it
was any previous a there are a lot of
you will never do good on the movie
there are only a couple reasons there's
only two edges which Zora movie am I
gonna walk out whoa why would I walk out
of the 1940s movie I guess that's fair
but I didn't know it became yes The
Legend of Zorro I know they made one a
couple years ago but I couldn't remember
that I was like maybe there was an eight
hundred years ago it's like a decade
you'll remember I didn't see it
okay now that Zorro is destroyed are
back to the super check
Cloverfield from insane Cloverfield what
a weird ass what a weird ass wanna go to
interesting alright who we got next on
the list
Britany laying back Thank You Britney
lane by the way the photo of my profile
is my daughter one more movie that was
awesome
more bound and flubber with Robin
Williams I really like flubber
what's homework bound again homeward
bound is the one with Michael J Fox
Sally Field and I can't remember who the
other one is but they're all animals two
dogs and a cat and they get separated
from their family and they go on this
cross-country you know harrowing
adventure to get back I'll tell you what
it's not it's not The Legend of [ __ ]
I don't think it's unreasonable to be
like maybe they made two movies I can
tell you is the mask of Zoro is great go
watch the Patrick H Williams video as to
why if you need to remind the masses or
oh it takes out the sword he's like who
takes up this or aspire that the high
swing hey you put the pointy into the
other guy so good anyway Thank You
Brittany Lang do you say how do you dot
it for me I mean she's your daughter
don't know that's not creepy
tell your daughter I said hi and she's a
great mom Pam recovered just like that
greet your daughters on our behalf from
a very wide distance John Donham thank
you so much for the superjumbo oh dude
this is like a block of movies I grew up
with angels in the outfield now you
can't yes we're always watching I love
them he's a great movie yeah Christopher
Lloyd and little jiggle I've never
watched a baseball game the whole way
through in my entire life still not sure
how the game is played I've ever seen
the end do base but I very different
than the beginning loving they should
remake that that is a great bad is a
good movie we'll shake it or do an
updated soft reboot sequel where we make
it it's a good movie Danny Glover here
with women demons in the
I'm saying there you go easy solution to
justify remake a woman in there for free
Larsen she won't give a [ __ ]
probably would I don't know if she
wouldn't give a [ __ ] about our opinion
of it oh what's that bear of course yeah
I know it would work that would yeah
would work
I mean you could easily redo the movie
with just like a various cast of angels
what's the Penny Marshall movie league
of their own extraordinary league of
their own meets angels in the outfield
yeah yeah we made it work literally the
pitch and it would be even fly it would
be fine it won't work thanks Chuck done
am Eric horseman thank you dude
thank you Eric horseman jerk you off
late for us Moe's out there The Wizard
of Oz oh hello well have you seen the
Wizard of Oz I oh my God thank God Jon's
actually seen a [ __ ] movie I know
you've really been outpacing me on the
amount of movies seen in this last good
good thing you're up to speed under
siege to was on a train Tim Wang visits
Tim wing okay The Wizard of Oz I think
still holds up it might be one of the
best book adaptations of all time I know
this because I'm so [ __ ] I have not
heard it said by other people well The
Wizard of Oz is that rare film that like
if they said they were gonna reboot
Wizard of Oz which Ames Franco directed
by they said they forget a reboot Wizard
of Oz um I could see that happening like
I could I could see the exclusive
collider Co the works and they have a
lot of a lot more Oz books than I
realized and I could see the idea of
them going yeah we could do
but when you watch Wizard of Oz it's a
perfect film you shouldn't touch it you
shouldn't touch it there's nothing you
can do with that that's no I think I'm
really excited to see Dan Stevens as the
mocap CG lion because that was my senior
Beauty and the Beast joke I just
rewatched it it holds up to my opinion
of it from a couple years ago when did
you rewash it last week oh really what's
the runtime of that it's a couple I
almost two hours you know what's funny
is John has not seen the last two
episodes of Buffy the Vampire Slayer but
he made two hours of his time to rewatch
Beauty and the Beast it's either I eat
in other people's company or I do it
alone with my computer you might as well
do that where your computer I watched
all of Breaking Bad on it on a laptop I
think I did too or my iPad some starties
femme failed tail fan fail tail him fail
tail yeah oh my god you and my mom would
get along so well
femme fatale tail tail Stargate sg-1 and
Star Trek Voyager I used to be able to
quote every episode of Star you or hurt
you with a quarter it started Jesus
Christ that is so much that's so much
dialogue I got super height when the
Netflix disk of Voyager came I've only
seen the last episode of Star Trek
Voyager where they finally get home you
should work your way back I was like oh
yeah I want to see how they got to
leaving home the first time and you know
it's funny
there is Stargate fun fact thank you for
bringing this up have you seen starting
a sg-1 the movie I haven't seen of any
of the Stargate in fact two Stargate
wait wait you've never seen the like the
Kurt Russell zine none of Stargate
Stargate was like Stargate is an even
bigger a sci-fi blind spot for me than
Star Trek and Star Trek is a pretty big
blind spot for me but yeah Stargate
yeo-hwa - oh just
the first movie it stems from there I
didn't really know that I thought the
show was the thing no it's the movie and
then they add sg-1 the movie which was a
writedown what's funny what I thought
people don't realize is a Stargate sg-1
was an r-rated straight-to-video movie
okay okay and the first Stargate movie
worker Russell and James Spader's not
r-rated it's a wonderful pg-13 flick and
the sequel were yeah well who's the guy
plays MacGyver what's his name Harry
Dean stick Richard Dean Anderson
the gap is MacGyver took over the
crustle row because of the
straight-to-video and then so yeah sg-1
the movie r-rated you see some pubes in
the film oh boy that's a lot that that's
X that's actually a rarity for that
point in time and then it spawned us
this TV show which is not r-rated and
it's became as mega hit and then they
have Stargate Atlantis and the Stargate
Universe continues so does Stargate sg-1
is that short for Stargate Stargate 1 or
is there another I don't know John why
don't you just go out there and watch
them I will go out there and watch Oh
here towards Inc go geared toward zinc
aluminum wants to FaceTime that's right
we were talking about this weird oh my
god who is John I hope you can keep the
livestream and I am for a minute you can
while I go get the shoes go get them
here towards ink oh my goodness geared
towards like everybody go check out his
various Instagram feeds and whatnot this
man makes beautiful shoes great artists
we should try and get you on this live
chat and as at as for Unisa Oliver this
is the problem is when I when I when I
try to think too hard about an
impressionist or it starts to really go
but you know yeah that's that's what
happens when Greg leaves the room and
he's back now welcome drumroll if you
didn't why if you're one of the 2000
people who didn't watch the live the
unboxing last 12 years I know you are at
least 12 viewers more popular than I
okay get it right how do you get your
shoes on your feet every day looks
chubby because of theirs Heath Ledger
pocketed john's bikes because this job
because on the way I made this you this
Joaquin Phoenix pump both from geared
towards being follow him on Instagram
man [ __ ] love these shoes on wait the
day the pen the day we can like you know
go hang out somewhere I'm wearing those
shoes I'm waiting for the right special
day to put those shoes on my feet
thanks for sure do are you gonna dude
you should wear them to the premiere of
the Batman I will yeah
geared towards Inc we do got a FaceTime
at some point though Jake you've got
someone the chat saying oblivion with
Tom Cruise eight years old doing that
was pan out which I I get why people
don't but I like I love it that was
great and a pioneers of the projection
screen technology that is a help in
movies get more crazy John is not boss
son only rates the nice Compton on the
mean comments even though you guys are
NIT seeing my movie still love you guys
not see my mu Quinton I'm gonna keep an
eye out now I haven't seen one yet
though very short I'm going I'm going
through here looking through a Mortal
Kombat Mortal Kombat was absolutely one
of my childhood movies Thank You Justin
for bringing that up
Bryan is saying the mask another
childhood 100% Archangel it's okay don't
worry
I just appreciate the thought our
accounts um alright so so John uh-huh
name this movie okay okay
use the element that brings life
water sees that quoting sub-zero
oh hey Goro is still pretty impressive -
of course yes this is the part where you
fall down
this is [ __ ] love Mortal Kombat man
oh don't don't spit in the grave I Spit
on your Conor Indian in the cupboard yes
in the cupboard big fans both is that
Joseph gordon-levitt
no which is a guy looks like a young
lord 11 you're not Charles Barkley or
some wannabe looks like dead like me HBO
show okay all right some adult children
growing up damn wait who's following a
chat people are fighting in the chat
wait who's inviting keep it fighting
that's engagement its engagement we can
use engagement keep fighting each other
yeah unless we have to give you the boot
so guys just watching my head you know
once you start talking about like you
know what DC and Marvel movies you you
you think are everyone's opinions on
suicide what really I'm glad that some
of these movies are getting a shout-out
though because this is some stuff I
thought people might forget about
especially like any in the cupboard
which you know I haven't heard about
since I was that old using the cover was
my pure fantasy man used to imagine
shrinking down to a little boy and then
you know making a Barbie come to life
and then I thought I'd [ __ ] that Barbie
as a little like a little dude and no
one ever find out because I put Barbie
back in it's like if you changed the
music and home alone
it becomes very different and basically
you had a similar to Experian
- what a lot of people have with the
weird science but just with slightly
less godlike power I mean anything the
cupboard it can be a really terrifying
concept when you think about it yeah and
also that goes both ways because what if
you like bring to a life bringing a toy
to life that's like a [ __ ] up toy if
you guys haven't seen any in the
cupboard it's about a boy who gets a
covered what if you and and he you put a
toy in in the cupboard yeah he turned
the key toy comes to life and so he's
got this little Indian guy this is the
best friend thanks just bring another
toys to life you know I can Night at the
Museum with Owen Wilson in that movie
like they're tiny guys they're come to
life that's what it is but with any toys
he wants the cowboy comes back gets
killed really violent one isn't doesn't
don't they initially start out as
enemies the cowboy Nene and then the kid
teaches them how to coexist and stuff
yeah the cowboy in any [ __ ] it's all
about tolerance child wish I don't know
I mean maybe if the movie holds up that
could be actual alright Anissa illumos
back alright Johnny got read her comment
and I'm so bad at math let's do our
pastry yeah you gotta thank you and I
just want John to do the Matthew
McConaughey voice the entire time when I
visit y'all I'm just kidding haha also
High School Musical was a childhood
movie absolutely was also it was a
childhood movie I did not see I never
see no joy no Troy Bolton in my life I'm
not even trying to sound cool because
only cool guys haven't seen High School
Musical you know I need to watch I need
watch Dazed and Confused Matthew
McConaughey okay Brad the bidet ox
to podo but dude Anisa is really making
some strong moves towards you I think
you got it you got it home go I'm gonna
keep talking in this voice alright
alright alright come down to Kilgore
text well take our shirts off I'm
talking to me about it directly John
look at the camera I like it talk to
Agnes you also don't like I like to look
at you and I look back at the camera
doing my best to not look at the screen
I don't know I see it's like you're in
the room it's like looking into it to
mentor you just put instead of like my
darkness I'm looking into like a void of
just Hollow emotions there's a good way
to are I just have a very colorful
outward personality today's theme are
you JA pocos in this man
loo again I love that there's a clue
love in the world are you excited clue
fans to have a new clue and do you want
Jason Bateman to make it oh yeah you
wanna know a fun fact do you remember
Haskell Flender from improv well they
all right
his dad directed idle hands and that is
Jana his dad also directed Conan O'Brien
movie
mm-hmm shouts out to the flenders learn
improv you did it so I said no but damn
big on that damn man I thought you just
didn't remember and I was going off on
another karate kick that's another one
okay oh okay what do we got here my bad
so behind here let's do this where we
yeah we are tardy we're going back up oh
my god I went way out of there I got
John help me Ellie live aid elevator
Thank You Eli Vader all my friends
wanted to see Super Mario Bros I wanted
to see Jurassic Park they called me an
idiot
I don't know going my mom best decision
ever ever since then I haven't spoken a
word to my friends I've hit them up
every week I'm going hey guys you want
to hang out I'm throwing a great party
at my new three-story house they always
make up some excuse why they can't come
over it's been 25 years come by my name
is Eli Bader I have joined the dark side
stop and keep saying they keep going mom
will you not would you go out with your
boyfriend today your fifth boyfriend
please this is like do can't we just do
one movie just things have not been the
same since dad left sorry dad left to go
see Super Mario Brothers no idea Thank
You Eli for the zubur chat but yes it's
very sweetie you do really appreciate it
smart [ __ ] woman oh Jesus Christ I
can't imagine being in that dilemma but
both feature dinosaurs oh you know yeah
I can understand the conflict there dude
meet the what's what's what's the
dinosaur movie we're the we're we're
here we're not extinct how did you ever
do good in the movie trivia mode Andy
called we're back we're back did you
ever watch her back of course I watch
it's [ __ ] incredible okay in a dark
Spielberg produced it there are a lot of
movies from that era of time that I see
the thing is my movie watching
experience has got supplemented with a
lot of classic films and a lot of like
British stuff so there's a good portion
of things everybody else around me was
watching growing up that I was not and
we're back with one of them damn it
we're back stop listening John why are
you justified why you don't watch movies
I don't like him we asked her crazy a
super Chester I just noticed I finally
come oh my god visit me oh my god oh my
god we can't wait to read those Anisa
reading misses we're gonna stack in this
is and go to Travis in Deadeye six one
six okay
all right John Monster Squad is my
all-time favorite art and another little
yellow heart dude my god Anissa that's
what's gonna be right you're gonna yeah
I got watch [ __ ] you my comment for
people who don't understand the
reoccurring bit with an ASA I was gonna
say it's gonna be sad that sexy tongue
is gonna be doing
do you know but thank you for your love
and support of this channel this
enterprise and it's my mic this
multifaceted tone my concern with Anissa
is that she's going to keep doing all
these my failure of Anissa
pledging or patron she's contributing
all these super chats she's like no I
keep making they keep making the worst
jokes possible go all out there and then
one day she's gonna [ __ ] do a video
about us she's gonna take all my
irreverent comments that I've made about
her towards you and then go I supported
these guys and this is how they treated
me can't so correct a whole bunch stank
you're gonna be entrapped get ready but
thank you Anna superb
Travis Austin man that is a large you're
the hottie you you're the hottie Travis
Austin favorite movies from when I was
get our monster squad Howard took other
horrible movies probably will Oh Buffy
the Vampire Slayer
hahaha I have seen that have you know I
have movie how do so many movie fights
man if you have I got the question why
movies willow should be remade hmm
Warwick Davis
what's who you know willow did he know
he didn't play well he played a
different character in their movie but
uh Val Kilmer now how did you ever win
in the Val Kilmer segment of the movie
trivia shmona
Travis cool there's some good picks Ice
Man Howard the Duck I think has become a
cult favorite Monster Squad gets a lot
of love now a lot of love Wolfman does
have one hour
kids grow up they remember the monster
squad that's what I've noticed monster
squad and nobody shouts out Buffy the
movie enough Joss Whedon only wrote that
right he didn't actually direct it yeah
and from what I add I don't know what to
believe that from what I understand it's
that case of you know this really wasn't
my vision for this Wow well Travis
Austin thank you so much buddy that's a
that's a very very generous contribution
you have made there thank you and then
now let's go over here and then we'll do
you then we'll go back to the 100 dead
i6s thank you so much dude that's very
generous you have also left a comment
here that is very much in tune with the
video that we are putting up tomorrow
which kind of sprung board the topic for
today I have three favorite childhood
cartoons Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
gargoyles and biker mice what's biker
mice from mars I've never heard of that
dude I haven't either and my best guess
is that it came off that period of time
where we got like samurai pizza cats and
and the likes street sharks or whatever
we're like everything had to be an
animal who's like the Ninja Turtle
basically I don't know like one of that
so that's my best guess is that they're
probably just another Turtles knockoff
dude
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles definitely
a childhood show 100% hang gargoyle
sorry
yes something that we actually that's
there's video pretty tomorrow where we
talked about like a big part of it was
discussing gargoyles did you know it's
gonna be hit on what reacted to did you
know that gargoyles was cancelled
because the ratings were not able to
compete or do better than Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers so they canceled that [ __ ]
and did you also know the elderly
gargoyle is a family friend of mine you
don't say yeah gargoyles and teenage me
Ninja Turtles great cause I have no idea
what biker mice are my Dead Eye sick
someone says thank you yeah you have
brought my eyes to life Oh with your
very big generous heart thank you dude
you're very very sweet or woman dude
woman that's recalling what's up dude or
what's up woman some would
much like the gargoyles and gargoyles my
stone heart has been broken yes and my
real beating heart has climbed out for
you so thank you did I also I love your
icon by the way your your avatar Thank
You Deadeye six-on-six and I and uh
Travis Austin you guys are so great
everyone who's been contributing so far
seriously you guys are very generous
thank you Courage the Cowardly Dog okay
well so we got in here what else we got
here I don't want the closure no I don't
Spaceballs well Spaceballs a childhood
movie of yours no ice us Falls probably
in my early 20s no late teens probably
yeah it was like I was I was like just
becoming an adult we make this fun John
continued the conversation it was not my
child now a Blazing Saddles was for me
and a young frankenstein those were my
milk bro by Mel Gibson movies those are
my Mel Gibson I had a maverick was our
Mel Gibson movie was it yes my sister
had a huge crush on Mel gives him back
in the day and we watched maverick eight
lot of times you never told me Diana had
a crush on the Mel uh-huh yeah yeah it
was one of the few it was like Liam
Neeson the Mel a couple other people but
uh yeah you realize how much better my
rapport would be with your sister if I
knew she was a fan of the Mel G yeah you
know because her and I like I really
haunts the tension in the room
functionality that really could have
gone some constantly awkward on with her
yeah if you only you had one way of
connecting hey you know that's not too
late he's doing great now he's got
damnit John she loves his recent work
just as mine I assure you is absolutely
ooh Sleepy Hollow wait what
Allen movie yeah actually I think so
yeah cuz it came out in 99 to 9 to 2001
you know no but yeah I definitely saw
that a little because you know that was
one of those movies where it's like it
was Halloween time there's there's all
really sex in this so we can do it you
know even though it's dark and freaky
okay okay okay okey wait what go back up
really quick what to wear no it makes no
sense we have to say go back up early
never watch a comment oh sorry
I didn't mean to bust Jesus Christ Chuck
y'all lets you go back to what you were
doing Eric oh remind me of whatever you
said about gargoyles being your first
something or other ah man I have no
interest in the new Hunger Games movie
comet just came in what's there's a new
heart our common thread is going like
bananas on our end you guys can't see
this but it's like just like fluctuating
up and down like I'm having a hard time
keeping a lot of commentary Dead Eye six
one six is a dude sorry about that man
but thank you all right John you broke
Ivan's heart I don't I I'm sorry I'll
try and mend it though just let me know
what I can do for you and I will all
right a people pleaser so everybody put
in their request guys John's a people
pleaser so really take advisor at the
Trader Joe's like I'll help help in a
way that's gonna really destroy my own
operations around the world in 80 days
the the original one or the Steve Coogan
one Dark Tower wait a minute so for
around the world in 80 days remake you
go with Steve Coogan and not Jackie Chan
he's who he lead who do you think Steve
sold more than 80 days it was Steve
Coogan or Jackie Chan Jackie Chan nice
shot I can be City Lethal Weapon 4 with
her neighbors
no I've seen lethal weapon for gently
he's not the biggest name in that movie
but he's uh name not that Rene Russo I
suppose is not a name who's bigger
renamed phone calls and everything John
it's good it's a good game with the
scene of the year is that the woman the
kid breaks his arm and then gets the
ability they like throw the ball 90
miles an hour or something like that one
with Dennis Quaid no that's the rookie
right that's the one where he like goes
to the game Oh John knows the difference
it's been rookie and Rookie of the Year
but doesn't your boy wanna do like
crawls isn't your buddy we're like super
into crawl [ __ ] you tried it's never
mind I miss miss took a word yeah guys
apparently you should tell people during
rush hour
great great one John hanging out great
ones we're hopping around here we got
two different why don't you choose The
Mummy three Ivan I love you but you're
it's don't mummy and The Mummy Returns a
mental Gerald a yes though
yeah dude brendan fraiser those still
cracked me up no joke we went to we went
to Dan and Lissa's wedding John Olivia
and I shared a hotel room John and
Olivia slept on one bed I slept I slept
on the floor empty soda and and then we
had we were in the city we've never been
to about six hours away as a beautiful
scenery Mummy Returns comes on TV
we don't go out six hours tired AF and
we're gonna watch The Mummy Returns and
that actually turned out a pretty
productive if I learned a lot about why
Brendan Fraser disappeared from holds up
really what
so fun this is like 90s Indiana Jones
they just don't make them like this
anymore do they
no they try to and they don't do
anything we go out to all the nature
[ __ ] that what's the mom hey hey hey no
Brendan Fraser's wife did not ruin his
life
but in bedazzled honey movie gaps why
fruit oh my god have you been following
that of course I've been following this
in every audio how's it looking to you
right now cuz I can't bring myself oh my
god way outside okay I would say that
really behind them superjet okay we
gotta block them you've never been to
China we try to go back and forth since
the comment on my regular chatter system
and then we chatter yeah comment below
oh yeah Oh Ellen Erica I'm glad you guys
are talking wanna peek Oh how's it going
our wonderful Hawaiian queen
hello and you're real never make that
mistake again stopping him say hi I was
just doing some modeling photos for
myself in the mirror that I'm gonna
share with the world also like six years
old and can remember going to see mighty
ducks too and my family fell in love
with it fav till this day dude The
Mighty Ducks are a classic franchise
don't remake it don't touch it
also number three Lana Thank You number
four Greg should really watch a mighty
ducks movie one two
do you remember the mallanna do you
remember this the Mighty Ducks cartoon
oh yeah like action hero yeah yeah yeah
yeah God why don't they do [ __ ] like
that anymore no I was like let's make
this a cartoon with
yeah like let's make this like more wild
and imagination me like take take
Scarlett Johansson Adam driver for
marriage story they make their marriage
worth making an animated film where they
just go around you know [ __ ] like like
kicking the asses of people who are
committing domestic violence they got
like lasers and [ __ ] so the Mr Bond kind
of cool show up in Revolutionary Road
and I start kicking a half irreversible
and start kicking ass telling you man
it's a yes this town is one big chicken
waiting to get plucked in Sotelo thanks
I'm a singer
thanks for the Louis Capaldi music video
reaction
I enjoyed if you guys wanted to look
more into his songs before you go music
video is really good too thank you so
much for the contribution that he and it
makes for being a patronage act as well
really appreciate that that was a good
song it was it was a very emotional it
was very heart-wrenching whenever John
is doing a music video reaction by
himself on our patreon and I'm not in
the video
I just dive a little bit on the inside
oh you should come and join me
no no I'm dying be because you're making
noise and I don't want to hear you when
I'm on my when I'm damn I [ __ ] this up
what was it gonna be you're on your
headphones and you can't hear me anyway
when I'm pressing my ear to the wall
listening to your every move I remember
when we first got Stardust we first got
start us this is a true story we were
living together oh yeah I remember I was
trying to meditate in my bedroom oh I'm
sorry
and then as I meditate in my bedroom and
then John just kept redoing good trying
to do the same Stardust so you just
could've hit that 30-second mark I
couldn't get it he couldn't get it down
Yeah right and I got so annoyed cuz I'm
trying to meditate all I hear it's John
repeating the same
like 15 times I go through what are you
doing I'm like I'm feeling the exact
opposite of what I should feel during
meditation I'm like [ __ ] it
I'll do it I attempted the starter and
I'm like [ __ ] this is really hard to
give 30 seconds problem it's hard and I
also have the compulsion to make sure
I've said what I wanted to say one time
John did a a review for a movie oh my
god was that ice cream truck or
something oh yeah I still feel bad about
that he did some review he cared so much
he had you God must have had like nine
different full takes you spent like
hours filming and you never did anything
no I mean yeah it was partly yeah just I
had so much footage and I couldn't get
on a roll that's that's something that I
do sometimes it's like a music video
reaction is easy to bang out because a
I'm chill I'm in my element whatever but
um for something like that it takes I
don't know very contemplative aren't you
yeah something like that
it takes I don't know yeah it was just I
was doing it alone and a review alone is
tricky and I written notes and and yeah
in the situations like that it's a
combination I want to just be saying
what I want to say and then if I get to
a point where I'm like it's hard to
detach myself from how I'm sounding
sometimes and so yeah all over I'll just
overcook it and that's what happens even
that better at that yeah yeah I could
probably do it no way less annoying
thanks I mean yeah you're way less it oh
yeah so yeah I still feel bad cuz I was
having she reached out and it's a it's
an odd little movie but it did leave an
impression there's stuff I enjoyed about
it
Olivia got me this much up Eric is
asking about much a lot I've never had
it before I only get like soy chai tea
latte from Starbucks and yeah she got me
just right she got me this one is
[ __ ] delicious
the only thing keeping me alive right
now hey Aaron Coleman Forbidden Kingdom
call out that's nice
idle hands I used to watch it all the
time - thanks Anissa - you know you not
to keep contributing to this for even
such a major contribution I think she
just wants to guarantee they're ready I
don't see sweat all the time - yes never
seen idle hands with the [ __ ] idle
hands that is yeah it's it's a horror
movie you know it's about a that I
haven't actually seen it but but yeah
Rodman Flender
let's look up the IMDB a log line for
really quick idle it's so much harder
when you're doing this with one hand and
you're like up pressure on you idle
hands here we go devon Sawa that's right
and Seth Green a teenage slackers right
hand becomes possessed remember Seth
Green yeah I used to be big I used to be
like a big fan of his bag what happened
to Seth Green man mostly does like Robot
Chicken and stuff
he was the least funny guy in Austin
Powers trilogy yeah although for
whatever reason I liked Scottie back in
the day I think I just thought he was
cool for some reason I don't know why
hooey 'then Holgate thank you buddy my
favorite childhood movie is the little
vampire that is such an endearing film
yeah you know it's fun to see like those
childhood like spooky movies but a
spooky movie but but without I mean it's
like you know I was like I thought that
stirred up the right tone also I've
never seen the little vampire and I just
reviewed it for you hey probably like
when we watched it in school but now
like not not qualitatively no I think
that one was was either not in my radar
when it came out or was a little after I
would have been watching it I had like
hocus pocus and Halloweentown and stuff
like that I saw hocus-pocus for the
first time last Halloween what did you
think it's a loud movie easy solution
loud did you enjoy any I did okay we
need a loud movie marathon Texas
Chainsaw whoo we're back to Anissa oh my
god okay what were all of John's watch
restrictions as a kid haha poor John oh
my god
no no no hard peih-gee 13 movies kukuda
child acting couldn't visit greg for in
glendale for his birthday cuz it's
dangerous out there I'll never forget
that oh do you remember that there's
Eagle Rock I remember I remember the
conversation and and the it was Eagle
Rock yeah because it wasn't Glendale
because I had been I hadn't been too
eager that's why I knew that because I
had been a good I was having her
birthday I invited John in Eagle Rock
was dangerous apparently yeah I know I
don't know why and a bunch of us came in
child acting John couldn't couldn't
watch The Simpsons I know if I brought
that up in this live stream you Simpsons
I mean that that came off pretty good
and my sister you snuck it in I snuck it
in with the TV because yeah I mean I
could get the on that why you know the
old antenna TV you could tune in for
that hour and a half long block of
Simpsons king of the hill and whatever
else but uh he wasn't allowed to watch
porn
I got it very strange my parents let me
watch tons of it my sister got me a
deport him since no but she was able to
lift the the veil for me she was able to
be like of porn yeah yeah John spam is a
very progressive house Matt Humphrey
household man yeah very kinky places
every time I walked in mr. Humphrey
Weiser dingaling out this is not the one
they choose I mean the I hope this is a
live streaming yeah we're working no way
I could have a very uncomfortable
awkward encounter with them in the
future
in person and then I bring that up on
the next live stream just have this
never-ending chain of
uncomfortable interaction is they don't
watch most of what we do but then though
I bet this is an hour and 42 minutes
into this livestream 45 minutes I think
the live streams are a little Leviathan
and then they're gonna they're gonna
just click on it and go where they talk
about they're gonna skip around it
somehow by the way the universe loves to
work they will hop on to this section
where he's like mr. Humphries tingling
right there
you know YouTube has a new chapter
system which would make that very easy
to do what with the live streams um you
know I don't know is have a chapter
called mr. Humphries ding-a-ling what is
this that I told you this I think if it
works the same way doesn't a normal
video I would assume it would work in
the live stream you maybe there's there
are some controls that have not appeared
for it yet but at least the basics yeah
you can chapter up your timeline okay
all right 10 elf all right have the
demons I thought you were thinking a
demon night for a second I was gonna say
the tail movie with Billy Zane and
Dennis Miller no no no Raj Krishna
has brought up a movie that I love okay
thank you - Raj
thank you for the contribution buddy
under siege an armor of God - are also
my list of movies and I used to watch on
repeat now we talked about under siege
we did Niraj by the way really handsome
gentlemen armor of god - or as you
Americans might know it it's called
Operation Condor in the United States of
America
and then when they release armor of God
the first one in America that's the
movie where there's a stunt in there
that is responsible for the hole in
Jackie Chan's skull they call that
Operation Condor two different orders
out here but yeah armor of God -
Operation Condor
Gretz gray jumps off a cliff and lands
on a [ __ ] hot air balloon in that
movie that is you and that anymore
I know man what the hell could being a
senior citizen [ __ ] and get the to
eject pop your AARP you know we don't
have Jackie senior citizens you in their
own stunts come on you're supposed to be
a pioneer was kids Philly G how's it
going what's a beautiful bastard a man
she draw GI Joe transformers the secret
of NIMH Tron Blazing Saddles and
Thundercats ho oh and the Muppets TV
show
Philly gee whatever sauce is not like
the other thank you so much for
contributing buddy that means a lot of
Philly G it's up beautiful sons it comes
I'm Philip DeFranco I can't build on
that I would love to fill in for Hilda
Franco I'm sure he would love it more
than you okay he-man classic she raw
underrated GI Joe deserves a better
movie because the cartoon monumental
transformers the cartoon so much better
than the movie the secret of NIMH while
the Overlook Tron it's crazy how it
would outdated effects that's so much
better than the sequel Blazing Saddles
might be Mel Brooks's best comedy
Thundercats ho Thundercats should get a
reboot or pick it up with the original
cast and the Muppets TV show man Jim
Henson genius fun fact I've never seen
and part of me wasn't entirely sure
oh gosh all these new super Chad's every
comment
even in the in just the non-super chat
section like like Oh a know people talk
about holes and darkman that's a movie I
definitely need to see drama the
scooby-doo movie I've never seen it I'm
so vanilla bro don't even they live is
great oh wait a minute on this day one
year ago Avengers endgame was released
in theaters hell was it yeah getting
that the theme what's your favorite
moment of avengers endgame ooh when Tony
Stark thank you for the super king of
the hill Erica that's a good choice I'm
glad to know we share that talked about
king of the hill on the video - moans
what it looks like a real law of
attraction thing happening here because
a lot of what you guys are bringing up
or is actually a lot of what we talked
about in the video or putting up
tomorrow
dragon soldier thanks buddy
yeah what is dragon soldier means I mean
like you're like a soldier for a dragon
or you a dragon who is also a soldier uh
make it queer
yeah a dragon soldier I would say make
it quitter but then I read dragon
soldier but make it quick big query I
was hey guys always loved seeing ya was
there ever a movie that scared you as a
child that you absolutely love now hmm
well okay I guess but by that question
what I think dragon soldier is implying
is that it's scary you so you were put
off by it and didn't like it but then
you got older and now you love it okay
it's not just you ducked away for those
scenes and came back yeah I don't like
this scene I scream scared the [ __ ] at
me when I was a kid I didn't but I loved
it you know so like what was the movie
that scared me so much that I wouldn't
watch it because it was just as a kid
but I got older and was like oh this is
actually really good mm-hmm
I feel I'm gonna clarify the question I
don't know the movie well no I don't
have a movie off the dome that I was
true
we may be house on Haunted Hill
originally scared me a lot when I was a
kid and I saw it and then you know I
came back not very long afterwards and
was like oh yes you know it's it's
obviously got camp in it but I came back
to appreciate it but the thing that
comes directly to mind for this is an
episode of The Twilight Zone called the
eye of the beholder because the there's
a face reveal that then becomes a big
part of the episode that really freaked
me out as a kid and liked that one and
the one with all the wax figures were
two episodes that I did not want to be
in the same room with and then later on
I came to really appreciate well and in
response to your question though dragon
soldier we got a lot of people in the
chat who are answering that and they're
Saint child's play
child's play revert well directed by Tom
Hall Lynette of all people yeah from the
webmaster star inspired oh yeah he just
the Aged philosophy actually fun fact
the coffeehouse we used to work at Tom
Holland the director would come in a lot
he was like a regular it was right
before he booked hi hey I was one of the
only person who really enjoyed my Tom
Hollands head on spider-man's body me
mmmm but I'm trying to think you know I
think the answer your question is like
Gerald in chat in response is saying
Halloween h2o or summer saying Jumanji
the spiders Jumanji Monsters Inc really
is your answer for that Robert okay
Bride of Chucky see I think the answer
for me will lie somewhere in a horror
movie that actually scared me when I was
a kid then I got older realize it's kind
of stupid but I love it and I'll get
back to you when it hits me I just like
how much Chucky that like Chucky I
didn't see till later and I had a
similar I just didn't think it was that
great and I saw it again I was like hmm
but it's everyone excited for the show
or no all right here we go
Oh Eric horseman dude you're already
like our highest page
like her biggest attributed patient your
thank you dude that's that's very kind
of you Eric I swear to God I give you
the best hand job when I see you buddy
and I'm gonna write don't worry
don't tell anyone I'll make you guys
look great
born queer and chill get used to it 1971
of course adding Bionic Woman the TV
show The Exorcist ah yeah see the extra
just get [ __ ] out of me I mean I I mean
growing up Catholic and watching that
much like we had before families all had
computers and laptops we had the
computer and we had the computer which
was in the kitchen
oh yeah and that's where I watch The
Exorcist for the first time without
headphones that there's like two and a
half hours to watch scary
much like broad daylight beautiful so
glad that you poltergeist is actually a
childhood movie of mine that is 100% of
childhood movie I still think it's
pretty [ __ ] scary
and Friday the 13th you know I'm not a
big fan of that first one I'm not gonna
lie um Elm Street that's pretty scary
haven't seen sleepaway camp haha
phantasm franchise what's phantasm
franchise phantasm is Don Coscarelli the
the iconography at least is there's this
old I think he's called the tall man or
the pale man he's this older what a guy
in a suit with white hair and it's got
this glass it's a metal sphere that has
spikes that come out of it if you've
ever seen and it's this yes yes I know
your supernatural it's kind of Clive
Barker II it's yeah very supernatural
out there horror franchise [ __ ] okay
kind of gothic I'm gonna watch it right
away Eric there's they've made many of
them and there's a dedicated you know
cult phone dude Fast Times at Ridgemont
High whoo
girl who gets out of the pool I just
learned about her recently when I was uh
so Sophie wait something hey phoebe
cates no no ice of you is that fast
times I thought that was the other one
that's what there was the other high
school I'm just gonna google it wanna do
this you want to do this you would have
failed us in the showdown no I'm worried
I'm wrong now yeah Phoebe Cates right I
don't think it a Phoebe Waller bridge
Phoebe Cates she's the girl in fast time
oh my god I was right yes okay Kate I
must have been watching a different she
she got married she's been married for
decades now to Kevin Kline did not know
that she retired from acting ha I was
just watching Kevin Kline and oh [ __ ] he
was in Holly I was beating the Beast it
was not a great story John Thanks was
definitely a growing up movie for me
they there's the scene where she gets
robbed with the big clown in the
background and oh what a that's that set
the SIRT that's a circus liquor which
was about a 1 minute drive from where I
lived
growing up in North Hollywood and when I
met Olivia she lived even closer to it
and every time we passed it I be like
that's where they film clueless and then
it got to a point where she's like I
[ __ ] know you told me that like every
time we'd have like what I want you to
love me more
coolest thank you eric oarsmen or as
icon eric Horseman's [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
bonk i thought this way about all of our
sister this is a little weights you
if you join in for a shout out or you
drop in a super hello come I don't know
if it's just coincidence whenever I make
a really really vulgar comment I notice
eyes on the stream just go down you know
family friendly family friendly people
here for wholesome innocence they come
to the real rejects alright let's see
what else is in here okay go back to the
super chats in a bit
the blonde which we means there's a lot
of love for hocus-pocus here man the
police academy franchise seen a few of
those hey have you guys seen the tune
sandwich trailer-trash up video is that
like worth reacting to I'm thinking of
dad doing it by myself about John
cannibal ooh
si Senor muchos Gracias de nada
thank you your vote Lords of Salem was
your childhood movie good good I'm glad
you're young chips
I watched the [ __ ] out of chips growing
up I wanted a motorcycle so bad and I
wanted to be friends with Erik Estrada
Paranormal Activity made me unable to
leave my feet out of the covers that is
a scary ass movie I think the Devil's
Rejects
I saw that woman you know I thought that
was weird as I started with my mom the
Devil's Rejects what was even weirder
was someone brought a baby to the movie
and the baby started crying during the
hotel scene and then there's some guy
who was by himself with the weirdest
audience there's me and my mom a family
some guy who's just sitting by himself
and then when the baby started crying
this guy like I'm at the top row my mom
like my 13 yeah and then there's a
family to the left and a couple rows
down and then a guy all the way to the
right a couple rows down baby starts
crying and then the guy just turns to
the family and goes
seriously and then just goes back to the
movie
that was the crowd I was with when I saw
the Devil's Rejects and it was like we
should start a channel it calls the
region yeah man and totally imbued the
channel with those values in those you
know aesthetics all right Pete Greg's
hairline I tell you guys I can't the one
thing I'm waiting for when this whole
pandemic thing is a settle down is I
can't wait to get my [ __ ] hair cut
because right now it's unmanageable and
it's also 95 degrees outside right all
right through hair Tanaka wear beanie
I'm just gonna wear here my hair's gonna
be in a bun for the next few weeks
that's it Oh Fish Called Wanda is its
riff have you ever seen that
yeah matter if ik movie have seen the
fish call one that's a good movie yeah
yeah I seen some movies a movie I've
seen a couple movies Titanic was a
childhood movie of mine as well you know
I do not see that too later my sister
saw it in the theaters Java censor
wouldn't eat a tank that's right it said
John there's nips in there as John's
dead but his penis away I am
contractually obligated not to late to
the chat today things I never would have
revealed until I really needed the money
ed Edd n Eddy yes
oh no jeepers creepers though you know
what I'm so surprised that no one has
brought up in here in terms of favorite
childhood movies and shows what no one
has brought up Rugrats no it shocks me
that not a single person I've read every
single comment it is Pokemon oh wow no
one's brought up [ __ ] Pokemon knowing
we had the digimon time we had an itchy
but I would not a single person like
Pokemon easily grew up on that [ __ ] like
Pokemon Pokemon ruled like our lives for
a while I rarely watch TV before school
but that was one thing
I would try and get up earlier to kiss
oh man that broke my heart when they
took it out of the mornings yeah also
like I remember when I got hooked on it
I was crying so early in the morning
when he's like I gotta let you go
Butterfree should know not to program
those things when kids might be going to
school I can give you but hey you know
you gotta learn about death and it's not
always convenient why is the show or
Pokemon the first movie yeah a lot of
people are like somebody a hot take
about poltergeist yeah yeah was you
don't think it was scary at all you left
her ass off interesting there's way too
much Pokemon John's Spanish ah Zoey 101
game so close to getting a role on that
show oh really that's oh yeah remember
that and then didn't Britney Spears his
sister like not want you to do it what
the [ __ ] are you talking I don't know
who's Brittany 101 Drake and Josh is
Larry I was on an episode of oh my god
what was it the Emma Roberts show Zoey
confidential no what was the Emma
Roberts show I don't know it's not
icarly or Hannah Montana no what was it
was an Etsy classic
well the Emma Roberts show is an episode
of that okay okay hold on let's see if
anyone in the chat says it no no no
don't stop Luke Jesus I want to see but
anyway I was on an episode of that and
she was a lot to put up with but I hear
she's really nice actually she's having
a tough day I was at one point that the
unfabulous
art gay friend Brendan thank you yes so
I had like one line and then I had to go
one point get pushed down the stairs I
remember what it was rumors I complained
about something about what she just
wanted to be able
and push me down harder instead of
getting like a stunt man in there and I
was like all right come at me bro you
can't believe I can't remember the [ __ ]
that sounds like undeclared and a bunch
of other okay thank you guys for
clearing that up
thank you I loved Halloweentown and I
and we actually did improv for a little
while with Jay Paul Zimmerman who did it
was the brother in Halloweentown yeah
you love to do this like voice that's an
improv pitfall there if you have one
character you like to do make another he
was a funny ass he was a funny guy yeah
all right guys we're almost to the end
here oh my god no focus up here so we're
gonna be combining all of yours at least
like bit by bit no no no we got this we
got this
MDS Omega thank you dude Austin Powers
in Big Trouble in Little China big
trouble actually yeah it's a I mean
they're more like childhood favorite
movies because my my family hated Austin
Powers but I loved it like that was like
a secret thing to my every guess in the
movie silence is why we take forever on
this [ __ ] super chat he compelled us
for three hours at home in here old
apartment at the at the end um hi [ __ ]
now go inside if you're a cinephile
leave no I got this all right so not
explain it in the movie basically being
Catholic is like illegal yeah you can't
do that and then Andrew Garfield has to
pretend for a while at astronomers gotta
go undercover basically and pretend he's
not [ __ ] Catholic at some point but
then you find out oh he has a cross
underneath his thing the whole time and
he's really been holding on to Lord
Jesus now that's kind of like my
relationship with Mel Gibson in Austin
Powers
I went through all that just to tell you
that MDS Omega thank you so much and Big
Trouble in Little China best John Wayne
impression I've ever seen yeah is formed
like that formed his Jack Sparrow who
the mask of zorro Connor Stephens thank
you dude what a mask his oral love today
do to Connor Stephens I [ __ ] love
this profile pic of you you look like
one hell of an artsy ass film director
dude you look like a guy who's either
really kind of understanding has a good
grasp of the human emotion in the psyche
or you're a very egotistical snob I'm
going with a big thank you Connor
Stephens the masses or not The Legend of
Zorro John I had a mask of Zoro never
make that mistake
Rocka do ridiculous hey guys sorry I'm
late I gotta say Iron Giant
we talked that's about Iron Giant you
know I gotta say Iron Giant growing up I
once thought one time didn't really like
it I didn't really care for it and all I
remember was the scene where he's
pretending to take a [ __ ] I love that
and then I watched it many years later I
don't know why I watched it I watched it
many years later and I was like this
movie's incredible this is like a really
good movie yeah I'm glad you were able
to have that second experience physicai
on John was a little bit of a late
praised movie for Disney or Pixar some
[ __ ] but I think I came around I feel
like it landed and and I mean somebody
more versed in animation can correct me
but I feel like it landed and it did
fine but I feel like yeah the love and
it's status has definitely accumulated
and stood the test of time so I feel
like it was one of those that yeah maybe
didn't like explode onto the scene but
definitely held on which is nice
powering today what did anybody ever get
into the other kinds of Power Rangers
because I only ever did Mighty Morphin
and there was like Power Rangers Dino
force there was ninja tech there were so
own oh it's supposed to look like that
Jason we know what it looks like a
stolen right now is texting me
problem is if you're if you're following
along this portion here we used to be
able to make the full screen but with
the new studio setup we haven't figured
that out yet
yeah so that's where the super chat
thing goes for right now but you know
stay tuned but thank you for your
vigilance we'll figure it out eventually
always looking out for our video quality
Anna I appreciate you we should twerk it
all right I can try I don't have enough
booty though
Jerell go get some sleep thank you for
being here while you've been here go get
some twerking Ethan Holgate is saying
haunted honeymoon underrated Gene Wilder
movie
I don't know review review haunted
honeymoon because let's not waste his
super chat John you know haunted
honeymoon man it may not reinvent the
horror comedic wheel but it's an
underrated gem in a lot of way I mean
gene Wilder is never not great and he
really brings you know if you're a fan
of Young Frankenstein and some of the
other more edgy you know kind of horror
tension films he did this is perfect for
you to revisit so double feature it man
I love this movie Thank You Ethan okay
baby Ethan Holgate seriously for
bringing that back to my eye my memory
and heart my favorite Power Ranger
season is the first season okay here we
go
here we go oh man I can't wait to get a
B on burger yeah
rizo gaming wait do I know you look very
familiar
you think I who I met at that hotel yeah
I know whites party I definitely know
your avatar and I know I but now his
dollar signs from a different spot I
know I see it a lot I've seen you from
somewhere you're you're very familiar
you Darth no I think he's coms a lot
it's you Ryan Beatty
he might face them all right dragon
heart oh how could I not think a dragon
heart definitely a childhood movie dude
and Dave my humble ops one yeah him and
and and if you want to see David Thewlis
played just like a sickly [ __ ] is like
watchin watch half his filmography I
know you think that he gives up this
looks like a pervert
he's a natural fervor look but no more
so than in that movie because her hair
is weird hair and he's always like Nick
so yeah he's full / vibes in that movie
big perv energy Treasure Planet again
Thomas the Tank Engine or to show Greg
read this and a high pitch Robert De
Niro what what's a high pitch a Robert
De Niro Thomas the Tank Engine for TV
show Greg thank you thank you so much
okay the Iron Giant is Dorothy onna
all right the Iron Giant apparently had
a terrible advertising campaign when it
came out it didn't do well originally
but it has gained more respect all right
good to know see how much John plays
favorites with you Erica Tuesday hurry
cause he knows you Megamind fluorescent
that's my favorite Will Ferrell Joey
have a comment here I see Joe I saw a
nice also al well cuz I've also
forgotten to let her know for like so
many of these that I feel bad over the
hedge dude
can somebody please tell me somebody in
this chat has some love out there for
the nutjob starring a you know Bojack
horseman what's this
see you guys can't see this but it looks
like when I do this I'm like oh okay
we're almost actually almost caught up
but then I do this and I'm like oh whoa
per scroll map this out Clarissa
explains it all
dude yes that I watched a ton growing up
and Doug sorry sorry Eric horseman thank
you thank you again Eric horseman and
thank you guys for for contributing here
so so [ __ ] sweet
anyone seen the Apple one of my favorite
really bad movies ever better than the
room check it out thanks man
hey dude brie Larson [ __ ] won an
Oscar for that movie it was a really
touchy subject of a film controversial
but very impactful and there's no way
I would say the Apple is better than
that movie now it's really hard to tell
her just really hard to top them all
right to say I even bother get it get it
yes brie Larson's captain marbles
because we're staring in an apple right
now any time we do a live stream this
late I owe my girlfriend dinner oh my
goodness
the Apple I don't know if I've even
heard of that I feel if it's a Canadian
terrible movie though I'll track it down
graveyard shift
hey oh look at that a mrs. st. John
never pays attention to me thanks John
thanks for making this look bad huh
Anissa I've been talking to you like my
I haven't talked to anybody else like
this all day I'll tell you
speaking of Anissa she's right here hey
off topic here but did John say a long
time ago that your dad worked on planes
trains and automobiles what did he do in
the movie industry at the time he may
have been a second ad I'm not entirely
sure that was that was the movie where
he had a slightly unpleasant altercation
I I've been told with John Hughes but
you know your dad slightly dad had an
altercation with the John huge that was
that when John Hughes slapped her dad's
ass
that's right that's right you can see a
lot of problematic you know sexual and
romantic themes in the works of John he
and my dad was directly subject to that
now uh my dad is an assistant director
currently in television but before he
had a full-on family with children he
was doing movies and stuff so yeah why'd
you answer that whole question like it
was an uncomfortable experience it's
also because whenever I talk about other
people I my mind starts to go would they
be okay with me talking about this or
like sharing any of this information
like it's just me being overly cautious
so I'll shed that
happy other people all the time did this
other day someone told me their worst
trauma that's a youtuber you guys are no
[Laughter]
let me tell you what happened in his
childhood okay try bearing the secret
for years this is my entire life
Ivan yes flight of the navigator good
call okay yeah but yeah no no the movie
was good yeah I guess there was one day
where they were losing the lights and
that's not what the man wanted to hear
at the time kinky Dora the explora hook
may or may need or the kinky Explorer
just pour in the holes with the back
door hardcore seems like a snore snore
in my sleep with the sheep count sheep
with the beeps my favorite flavor is all
these dreams my M&M is better in the
first hour my favorite flavor is you
can't escape mister high flyers what is
that is that like a Ben & Jerry slave
I'm not sure if this is flown over my
head somebody quick pinky Dora's trying
to tell you John if she wants you to eat
some
you can't escape mister high-fliers off
of her okay
I mean this is definitely not directed
at me must be directed at you maybe she
wants us both to eat a high-flyer off of
one of her shoulders or the top of her
head kinky Dora do you think it's high
fliers tag team I cyrus the coronavirus
what's your favorite hot hot fire
Cristi Elias revered it creates a
template it's perfect you don't have to
make okay
max Keeble it's a great movie we thought
David Henry was mad but he made the big
move Who Framed Roger Rabbit is a gray
one ooh that happened I have to just
call out great masters active by the way
oh yeah yeah yeah
that's a great one Space Jam yeah well
that's the rub I totally didn't realize
until recently I didn't connect it that
was Robert Zemeckis joint for Who Framed
Roger Rabbit anyway moving on are you
not after Bocas you're talking about
someone else right now I'm uncomfortable
because I'm talking about something else
right now I'm not sure if I should be
but also I guess it's fly away home the
one with Scarlett Johansson and the
geese because I definitely saw that as
well that was a good one anyway Eric
horseman thank you buddy did we do the
Hot Pockets oh we did not do the Hot
Pockets high fliers tag team hold on our
horsemen what's what's your favorite hot
pocket flavor well I can only have
cheese now oh all right but I used to
love pepperoni and sausage come by Oh
pepperoni and sausage is great did ooh
hot pocket sounds great lean pockets
dude my buddy
John out in Texas he had a friend who
worked at the hot Pyatt Factory and
would he had access he could get a hot
pocket fresh off the conveyor belt
before it was ever frozen so you could
eat it and apparently it's a whole other
experience but the the the cheeseburger
one if not the pepperoni and sausage was
my favorite because those were so
decadent okay we got some love with the
chaff for Kill Bill Vol 1 oh yeah that's
a good one right there also Eric
horseman got a cheers from Ivan Carroll
al however that we we live stream at
this hour because then we're getting
people who are also in the morning and
other parts of the world
good morning we have to discourse now
have a discord for YouTube proper and we
have a special private one for patreon
and people in the patreon who are trying
to cool
they're like you know so listen UK and
it's like 1:00 a.m. when you guys go all
right here we go
Eric horseman I think every freaking
movie ever made is gonna be mention yeah
I think so too
anything we could have seen before the
age of 17 and come on Greg and John need
to be voted hottest YouTube couples
sorry javi oh no no no no no no it's
definitely Tyrone Magnus and Scarlett
they are pretty hot I've been trying to
get them to do a video for me for the
longest time where went I wrote 1
million sperm I was I really hope that
even if we never find out just once in
his life the story gets back to him and
he does do it yeah that'd be great
oh I would be even happier if I never
found out I can't tell if olivia is turn
off the the air conditioning in here
where she put on the heater to be like
wrapped you don't have a red light we
just have future you guys you rock looky
loo well thank you Eric horseman that's
a really kind compliment of you thank
you buddy
hey that's not fair I couldn't see the
roof of the Little Mermaid a movie
theater all right an isso liver you
cannot make me uncomfortable by the way
I'm gonna read both these thank you Anna
so by the way you're so sweet so [ __ ]
kind you're you're right in here and
Tyrone thinks of you before he lets hop
it's 1 million sperm I played the game
akinator blueboard the other day try to
find y'all was mad I couldn't find your
brother Greg but not y'all the what are
you talking about it is this an app game
that we can play I don't like it when
mom and dad fight on this channel ha ha
as corny finally getting to y'all please
please don't drink bleach like the press
says well first of all ok I don't know
what activator is it sounds crazy and I
couldn't find your brother Greg
on the channel Jabbok away and he's
texting me right now completely unaware
that I'm on a livestream giving me
advice about how to make better live
streams saying stuff like the next time
we do a live stream here's you shim like
thanks I'm glad to know you are telling
me this right now when I'm already on a
line this is the most practical time is
we can just put it right into effect
I'll say and then uh nowhere yet another
quarantine ii-i've been enjoying the
quarantine we're home I crawled down for
the corn like yeah there's a lot of
stuff I would trade back for it but I
think there are some things that come
off the relief side that not half-bad
also old creep show pretty rad yeah and
I know you weren't crazy about it but I
like the maze a lot at the Universal
Studios oh yeah I didn't like that
amazing I wasn't a fan no one did V
what's up buddy you guys are so sweet
Joey should check out dragula on Netflix
the BLET brothers think of it like
RuPaul's Drag Race but with a [ __ ]
twist oh yeah that sounds awesome let's
do it I mean out that by that I mean I
will thank you thank you by the way
Brendan beaver yeah appreciate the
recommendation that's a perfect name for
that too
oh my god I hope does Rob Zombie ever
appeared I'm sure they had to at least
talk to no they probably maybe didn't
cuz that's a monster never mind this is
great I'm here for Oh Mike what's up
Michael ruko Michael yeah you know who
this person is I do he I mean he and
Erica and their buds and and we hang out
a lot together Mike is a great animator
he's uh he's working on some loony
you're still working on way any tunes if
you know him can you ask him to increase
the amount he's super Jenna okay you
sent him a text yeah I'll get him on the
hire more people right this minute
oh I miss you Mike I haven't seen you in
such a long time
mike is great he does a terrifyingly
close impression of the Gopher from the
winnie-the-pooh show okay and he can
take any scribble that you make and turn
it into a Garfield and that's that's
true life and someday I will be what is
the story of stank foot
I have not Mike I'm so sorry III feel
bad for not talking to you find out did
you get to the bottom of the I'm telling
Olivia I'm buying no I have not seen the
story of stank foot and I will ask but
thank you so much for tuning in oh my
god alright and and yes we do need one
day we um involve your animation
expertise animation expertise we got
Ryan Beatty over here in the chat
staying up till 4:00 a.m. o rings now we
could be up at 7 a.m. to go to sleep I
think I'm gonna make you one of our
discord monitors um well hey I want you
to tell you from Michael hmm thank you
thank you Mike
from Greg don't mic Greg told me to tell
you that he said thank you
cuz he's too embarrassed to say it to
himself Jimmy freckles bigshot in 1987
the last dragon never end his story Red
Dog Big Trouble in Little China name a
few those are some good pics right there
never seen big shots I've seen the last
dragon actually I enjoy that one what
was the another one I grow some reason
maybe think of Dragon Bruce Lee story
which made me go to Brandon Lee rapid
fire i watch the [ __ ] out of that one
neverending story Red Dawn big trouble
oh good comm what's big shots you don't
that is big shots isn't that a parody
movie that's uh no I'm thinking of hot
shots is I might be a hockey movie I'm
just guessing man big shots all look it
up okay Erica Tuesday oh wow she
actually Erica how you doing Eric is a
good friend of ours she's in love with
me and I've been like Erica please I
feel like you've met Mike
I met Erica have you met Mike yeah I met
Erica if you feel like you've been to at
least one borough Yeah right at me and I
I saw her just like almost faint and I
was like Erica please you're
embarrassing yourself and John was like
Erica love me though I want your
attention Erica and I it's an hour too
fun fact Dolly Parton privately helped
to produce Buffy the Vampire Slayer not
a Lucille Ball who helped privately
produce the original Star Trek series
what Lucille Ball produced the Star Trek
series I vaguely remember this
information I did not know about dolly
though that's that's really cool though
damn I would love to hear is there any
like accounting for do they ever talk
about it like I'd love to hear what
inspired them and what it was about
those projects because that's pretty
sweet
plus I mean you know dolly and Lucy
pioneer in for entertainment do erica is
such a funny person she sent us a video
and we just started like laughing I was
actually genuinely funny you know
sometimes you're like ha ha ha the
people in text
we were actually ha ha ha mm-hmm you're
just saying
ha ha ha ha ha yeah no other just our
mouths out but like [ __ ] robots yeah
the goddamn Coneheads oh no oh Dolan
Dolan you should ask beyond the trailer
well thank you Jason 21 texted me I
think you had sex me to be like hurry up
and get to your [ __ ] super chat will
do now this year or move to 2021
that's definitely move to 2021 not I
think most movies are in the mood get
moved to 2021
most movies I think it's smart too a lot
of people are not gonna want to be in
theater because you get think about it
even when they open a cup the country
even when they decide to John you're not
invested right now and they all side to
open the country not oh oh wow
so you think just because you caught the
last of what I was saying
that means you were actually invested oh
I'm sorry sorry I cook this dinner for
us but you decide to be on your phone
can send your mother's the text message
I don't need your permission but no I
think most rumors are gonna get moved I
feel a lot of whatever they're planning
on releasing this year will ultimately
get moved because even when this country
opens back up it's not just this country
along the unifier and here's the whole
world
and it's not like you're like alright
you can start going out and socializing
people are still gonna be cautious for a
while it's gonna be a while before we're
truly comfortable even myself like I
miss going to La Fenice that's what I
miss I missed that more than actually
going to a movie theater right now
because I know what's this whole thing
like we're able to stop being
quarantined I'm gonna be paranoid to be
in a theatre cuz you're like well [ __ ]
you know who am I sitting next to in the
theater who's behind me who's in front
of all these things it's hard to keep
let's it's like our theaters gonna do a
giant remodeling system you know some
art in here or yeah are they gonna come
up with some kind of new like I gonna
put hand sanitizer dispensers in every
seat or they get a space seats part
that's actually that is I hadn't like
just specifically thought of that but
that is also true it's like even if
things get better in America I can't
imagine some of these movies are going
to premiere mm-hmm because yeah you
don't have the international market and
and you should and I mean you know just
something to think about
yeah Matthew Holmes is saying you do oh
hey yeah thank you I just missed my
girlfriend and I really wanted her to be
here texted her to come in well jump
when John you're texting you're like you
were things oh no you weren't
I'm gonna do like look like we're in
really quick ones really quick ones you
know I haven't said in watch you wash
you gob did you cry that's what she said
about us the other night oh no it was
really short
it was embarrassingly short you know oh
okay pleading for a second shot she was
already in the shower
she was already on the drive through she
was off she was back on bumble I was
even helping her find hey let me find a
suitable place let me find something at
least gives you my problem and then I
slept in here thank you have the ohms
babe babe read the next super read the
next Super Junior right here for Brendan
V he's is one of our subscribers I just
feel weird we've made all the jokes with
him about like yeah I gave subscribers
but now that I'm just saying that of you
but now it sounds like a joke Diego Luna
I think if you made a young Indiana
Jones adventures type TV series that
would be the way diego luna's like 45
yeah when they're 60 they are really 18
years old it's not just an appearance
it's underneath the skin there they have
the cellular regeneration of an 18 and
I've always wanted to be with an older
woman to birds oh that's right when
you're at the hospice center that should
have been my first clue what would you
call it I don't want to say the title
that just came into mine so let's go
Thank You profession baby make you so
much better oh you are a high this is
what you need to do is like every
livestream has to have like a few minute
segments where you pop in it's like the
Olivia segment yeah the the ice pirates
was a favorite childhood movie of mine
nice pirates yeah I didn't grow up with
it
well Jason Dolan heard of white and
actually 65 years old we don't know what
the ice pirates are I always think of
Time Bandits when I hear ice pirates
unfortunately which is a Terry Gilliam
movie it's really good Robert narrows in
great facts John ant that's great thank
you
and Michael's right here for the fun
scifi of enhance the live stream with
your fun facts got another super chat
guys I love this poster though it looks
like a gem that's got one of those
drawed Ian's can really see it John
let's check this just for the sake of
argument like well we're trying to make
sure the people whose we try to them
that the people were super can be shine
here
okay then totally forgot Eric horseman
in Clash of the Titans Harry Hamlin wank
not Sam Worthington speaking of Titans
Harry Hamlin and Maggie Smith speaking
of Titans strong side
Olivia has forced me into something I
loved watching her with another God of
War beat I beat God of War and a lot of
playing God of War was not a lot of me
figured out how to beat certain parts a
lot of it was Olivia don't go to bed one
extra [ __ ] do I solve this puzzle and
she would do this thing where she would
stand in front of the TV be like go here
I'm like you're blocking the TV
I can't see who you're pointing when
you're standing right there then I get
mad then she'd leave the room mad she
gets mad then we both leave the TV
anyway yeah there's tied in there Zeus
Kratos is this a epic yes I know there
are gods with Zeus is one of the main
characters in clash of titans and Kratos
is the son of Zeus right so thank God
who per second I was like but one woman
is too are they related oh my god
Zeus be [ __ ] they should Zeus would
get canceled in today's culture oh yeah
he turned his wife into a cow or
something
oh god Zeus was the man yeah that's the
great this thing is like you know you
look at our religions now and it's like
sigh tillich heaven back in the day it's
like we pray to these guys and they're
doing their own fucked-up thing upstairs
and we got to keep them happy
no segways now
Wow Anissa look at Anissa look look how
much he look how much she loves John 3
super chats in a row that's how much she
loves John neither and 9 none of them
have my name ok but we know she's trying
to get here it's quite a van you at the
gas station so she's talked about you
know like hey we should all hang out the
four of us and I know what she's trying
to do is like the four of us hang out
and then she's like oh I gotta go John
can you drop me off at the gas station
bathroom so we can do it in the gas
station Lee with Aneesa so it's a very
specific fan fiction for music reaction
to feel you now buy dry the driver you
write it down John let's do this or
screenshot it make your life easier with
a screenshot there as anyone ever told
you that you to have the best smiles in
the entire world did you all wear braces
as kids I did and happy my mom did it we
should have the other parents didn't
let's be
bad lives in bed you hear that baby we
have the best smiles you agree yeah but
do you agree that we have the best
smiles
you don't think we have the best smiles
John and I oh come on John and I have
the best smiles watch third best teeth
in the game my modeling pose dad that's
why I have a hundred Instagram followers
on my personal modeling page yes take it
off you're gonna get free underwear soon
enough I was trying to get bang energy
[Laughter]
Vince you're delusional stage all right
there was a third one from Anissa though
and she says that a beautiful woman is
my girlfriend goosebumps all I used to
love for now why is the viewership going
down weather is the most scary messed up
movie to me messes me up now till this
day watched it for the first time at my
cousin's house never again whoo that's a
sore subject for Jenna Fischer and James
Gunn you know they're not together
anymore I know that meant awkward
between them they're not friends you
don't know James Gunn or Jenna Fischer
James Wan and Jennifer Garner yeah I
mean that James don't work he directed
them co-starred it co-wrote it yeah all
right baby you can go baby
you can go your shift is done all right
guys energies back in the game let's do
this all right
well slow that I think is actually a
very underrated movie as well mmm-hmm
it's got a good pulpy blend of that's a
good I think horror comedy that has a
more horror than comedy blend you know I
realized next livestream we're ordering
a pizza
yeah I love the worm's effect of that
budget tomorrow is another very
underrated movie - you guys got good
calls you're worth it Ryan
all right the Brendan V here Thank You
Brendan V where we at scary scared the
[ __ ] out of me as a kid especially the
ending yes I was trying that's another
movie I watched as a little kid [ __ ]
parents should censor me now that I'm
older I really appreciate both a novel
and movie but I definitely prefer the
musical it's not a bad call yeah
is there an actual musical carry the
musical yeah there's one they they put
it up on stage in fact I tried to go see
it but um then they did it on Riverdale
I think so it's it's a thing yeah yeah
did I carry the musical episode carried
that that movie actually really
influenced my life in a lot of ways I
remembered got my first period I got my
first period while she got her period in
the movie when when I watched that movie
I must have been like I was I definitely
wasn't in high school yet and I
remembered thinking like when when I
start dating I'm gonna go date girls
were kind of like Carrie before she went
off [ __ ] serial killer on everybody
but yeah I'm not gonna be mean women I'm
not gonna boy I'm gonna pretend to be a
protector a vigilant guy about the whole
thing
Gotham's White Knight and then and then
now I'm about to be 30 and Olivia is my
protector my battles I'm not attracted
to carrying in my life I've tried to
carry of Carrie turn into a [ __ ]
superhero you know but that's not so
true Association I have with the movie
it definitely influenced my teen years
it definitely did I'm dying to see the
Evil Dead musical I feel bad that I
haven't yet I have a copy of the script
though so one day we'll do a live
reading hey Ian to tell a buddy just put
them the requests on patron thank you
for your super chat dude John take a
screenshot of it thank you dude Eric
horseman totally drunk as [ __ ] right now
buy some TP if you can find it with this
haha thanks man now send that five more
times so that we can cover the Austin
slated to you thank you dude not
seriously thank you dude Eric you should
it be drugged right at it yeah I feel
like you're gonna wake up in a year from
now like on the first sober day be like
where did I give all this money to these
reject people I'm just kidding man get
more drunk as the night goes up no never
stop being drunk
don't ever stop being you some people
we're so happy to see Olivia it's like a
family environment here it's like hang
out show there wasn't evil dead musical
as well one time we were planning to go
to Vegas and I was like we gotta go the
Evil Dead musical never happen I'm dying
to see that's my story that's what time
I wanted to go elsewhere but I never way
that's a low-key dream production like I
haven't been in a play or musical in
years and years and years but I would
love to do I would say pineapple is very
much an accepting topping on a pizza yes
okay I'm Pro pineapple I don't whoa I
know but I'm Pro Kamerion Ren foe top 5
anime 1 Cowboy Bebop
when I immersed our dating Olivia that's
what she introduced me to right away my
cowboy bebop fantastic number 2 yuu-yuu
hakusho i totally know what you're
talking about
no move two three two boots oh my god so
so stylish it's super bro Kenshin oh yes
yeah no I do diver gundam wing that was
jaws well everyone was down with Dragon
Ball Z I was like I want to be true I
want heavy arms I want to build my I
still have my Gundam unbuilt models
somewhere I was all about it I'm sorry
there I go sharing another life I
thought I was let me think have you ever
seen the producers China just find ways
to poke at you even if there's no sense
Anisa your oh my god where do you work
our New York or at the bottom to the end
of the super chats today we have a
chance to take it all back I think all
right unless we're behind something is
stole I have no idea what's going on but
in Mesa we can't see your final question
but we made it to the end I think yeah
there's that last thing on it Bobby Byrd
to this oh-oh okay get it alright okay
you guys can't see it
he's another third thing now you can't
see but thank you Nisa I'm gonna ask you
to stop just for now just tonight just
for five minutes just five minutes five
minutes three way too generous bordering
into or feel guilty now with the amount
you've contributed she was saying not
gonna find out by finding a brother on
games she'll look up the game it's
amazing oh my god we maybe we got more
solution so today and then her next
question is Greg I love you as well I
don't only come to this channel for John
haha I can't wait for next Thursday
livestream my birthday livestream well I
will be super chatting you $1,000 every
30 minutes for my birthday present to
you my birthday present is just see your
channel grow you all really do mean the
world to me I'm so good for the
friendship that we really are friends so
you know just it's no need to keep but
thank you though it's really it's really
Connie him now I can whenever I go this
late I owe my girlfriend dinner so
gladly buy her some impossible whoppers
thank you thank you but now we will be
contributing at least 10% of this or to
10 to 20% at the time you're not
annoying us it's more a question of us
feeling guilty this because you're
already such a supportive patron you're
such a cheerful wonderful human you're
so generous every license as a matter
words to tell you Eric horse
and do not give us your stimulus check I
don't care how drunk you are do not give
us your stimulus about it stretch it out
over several yeah can we get a payment
sir $40.00 install 24 you no need to do
that buddy yeah oh my god thank you guys
so much for contributing but we're gonna
call this a night right now but let's
read out some more quick ones before we
end it voyage to the bottom of the sea
favorite movie of 2020 oh man have how
many right now people are doing post
endgame once hi Rasheed uh Eric salud
angel fluorescent I've indeed even very
very interactive here like the peeps be
making friends in the chat today and
feel free there are links in our recent
video cop in comments to the public real
rejects discord but we also if you want
to join patreon the five-dollar tearing
up you can join our little private one
where we have boards for all the shows
we cover so you want to carry any of
this on for free or elsewhere you know
oh man we got some drunk people in the
chat yes it's the time if you're gonna
be drunk you're courting we need to
might as well drive streams someday and
then of course the last one as expected
there are beautiful woman oh my god is a
competition happening oh we're going
down the slippery slope of a super oh
thanks for she thanks for watching
scroll so many comments you can throw in
last minute
oh wait wait what I waited for it away
for words you go
Anissa one
thank you guys to everyone who's been
here this entire time thank you it was
just chiming and thinking who took a
peek into the curtain here
enjoy your trees I have not stood up in
the last few hours I'm glad to be
standing now here's one trailer-trash up
request this is Greg's crotch signing
off thank you guys very much well all
the love we'll see you on Thursday for a
solid one hour
here we go live once a week nope hi
Gabriel thank you no longer nor do
you've reached the end oh my god where
he says now the last great to waited yet
I'm really sorry if we did miss any of
you but yeah we oughta think we missed
anyone I think we're on top of it I
think we did a good job today thank you
so much guys this went on all right love
you love you guys day safe stay healthy
stay sane watch movies take drugs don't
go to school prescribe get money they're
all here all right we did it it's in the
bandana recon the party and the party
you just can't seem to find your way out
door leave the party where the pain